e
um Brian Sullivan um from uh Grantham
and ranking member uh for the committee
and
um I've been
uh let's see I started in 2008 18 was
chair 19 and 20 and uh have been on the
committee in the interim as well as
representative Michael Granger you guys
may know me as one of the guys that uh
whips for the gold sheets so I'm
originally this is my second term in
this committee uh representing Rochester
uh representative Brian L I represent
Bedford Hillsboro 2 uh I own several
small businesses in marac an adjacent
town to us and um I am the President of
the New Hampshire stob bile Association
at the moment for the next two years and
um happy to be here happy to help out if
I
can representative Mike dgo this is
actually my second term full times in
labor I own a business I've owned a
landscaping business since 2007 and uh
here I should have
started easier representative Jack
Flanigan uh this is my
uh fourth term in in this committee I
served two years in the committee I was
ranking
member my fourth term under chairman
Sullivan in between there uh prior to
that I ran for congress in
2016 when I was Majority Leader that's
why I missed out a term in labor I've
always been on the labor committee um
the uh background is insurance work as
comp I'm pretty heavy on work comp
insurance uh but I also was a uh
Schoolboard chairman and a uh selectman
in my town where I negotiated Union
contracts um so I got insurance I've got
uh collective bargaining I've got a
little bit of the unemployment situation
so I guess that's why they stuck me here
for four
that actually I was asked to be on
another committee but uh the speaker
them good morning this is is really loud
I'm Mark Warden out of Manchester this
is my fifth term my second time on labor
committee and U the last 20 years I've
been independent contractor in the real
estate business and my first careers
were as a I guess an employee W2
employee so I've seen both sides of that
as well glad to be
back welcome and in the back we have
Jamie Wyman you want to introduce
yourself
Jamie hi everyone my name is Jamie Wyman
I'm the committee assistant for labor
and all of the Committees that meet on
this side of the hallway so I do the
scheduling I print your notices I give
you your bills I prepare your blue
sheets and I will help the clerk and the
chair as well as the vice chair just to
make everything run smoothly I'm a
nonpartisan employee so if you need
anything anybody can come and ask ask me
for
help I I've worked with Jamie for the
last four years she's awesome so if you
need anything at all uh Jamie I'm glad
you're you're doing that we also have
Davis Allen Davis you want to introduce
researcher thank you Mr chair I'm Davis
Allen I'm a recent hire with house
committee Services as a nonpartisan
committee researcher I come to uh the
legislature from the Department of Labor
having served in the workers comp
Division and the Inspection Division uh
so I do bring a little bit of a
background that I hope will be helpful
to this committee um any member of the
committee is welcome to bring
nonpartisan research requests to me for
work that would support the entire
committee um any anything that is for uh
individual re research would have to go
over to uh OS um so again anything that
is nonpartisan research that will help
the entire committee is what I'm here
for that can either come to me directly
or you can go through the chair
first yeah and if you could just I mean
you can go straight to Jamie or or Davis
but please just copy me and let me know
and represent Solomon um as well just so
we know you know what's going on yes
ma'am no just okay good repr repres
presentative Granger did you have some
thank you Mr chair do you have like a
card or something so we can uh get in
contact with you uh I do not have a
business card contact informations in
here in the in the packet I gave you
it's on the third or fourth page in oh
thank
you cool thank
you all right so the format for today
really this is an organizational meeting
so I just it's about
establishing uh how we work as a
committee and uh uh it's an open
discussion so please you know if you got
anything that doesn't make sense and or
if you don't like it then let's discuss
it and we'll move forward all right um
the start times uh I
really like to adhere to what we're
doing so we'll start on time and uh and
we'll get as close we can as finishing
on time to B based on the the
testimony um the uh our days are
Tuesdays uh tomorrow is sort of an
anomaly based on the schedule um
but the the thought right now is with 17
bills we'll be able to meet each of the
next four
weeks uh and get our bills
done um and then uh so for example the
four bills that we hear today will exec
next week in the morning and then we'll
hear bills in the in the afternoon and
early or later in the morning and then
the next week we'll EXA those so um
representative solom I talked about it
that we neither of us like executing
bills on that day and so we will not
with the exception of tomorrow which is
a that's a oneoff with the uh we won't
EXA bills that day uh unless the two of
us agree that it just is easier to do
but other than that we'll will adhere to
that
schedule uh emails did is everyone get
I've sent out a couple of emails to to
the committee is everyone getting
those look
at okay I can't coach
that I just want to make sure I got the
right emails okay all right
um okay so dress and
decorum uh
typically the dressing form is business
attire and everyone in here is is
dressed accordingly so we can adhere to
that that's fine
um food drink in in here okay so cup is
all right if we could keep it underneath
and off the table that would be great uh
technically it's water only but I don't
know what's in your cups okay and I'm
not going to inspect okay food is really
a
nonstarter um and a lot of people use
the room and they don't clean it very
often so if we could hold to that and I
always have my
Altoids okay so this is not food this is
energy so I I make a clear distinction
there um but the idea is this is not a
place to eat lunch it's not a place to
eat while you're in committee um and so
that if we can adhere to that that would
be great use of electronic devices okay
it's it's about respect to the person
providing
testimony um and so you know obviously
cell phones off are are down um but in
in listening to testimony I like to look
and see to double check does that make
sense is that right so I don't have a
problem if you bring your computer in I
don't have a problem if you if you're on
your phone but just remember that we're
only here to hear what they have to say
and so respect to the people that are
taking their time to come up and talk to
us I think is what we have to adhere to
um but clearly if if you've got your
laptop or your tablet or your phone that
that's quite all
right please
um typically um I usually use my iPad
for or a device um if we're dealing with
Department of Labor and they're
referencing um particular rsas it's
quick to U instead of printing everybody
out it's quick for us sometimes to look
them up while we're discussing with them
to make sure that we were talking about
the right points is that okay yeah oh
absolutely y excuse me to that point are
we going to get copies of the LA book as
we had previous times do we
know I don't I'm not familiar with that
uh you have copies of the bills I know I
was just curious
Chang we used to get a copy of the lsrs
of the lsrs or the bill I me not the LS
I mean the labor bills oh yeah you got
them in your packet Y no no no mean the
statutes the rsas statute right we used
to get the book from the labor okay I oh
yeah I've seen that no no I know what
you're talking about but I'm not
familiar with that being in the
committee and outside I think they're
right here yeah no we used to get a do
you recall shortened yeah years ago I
we if if you want one
then I think it then get Davis can get
it for you okay but I I don't I don't
need one um and so if you want one if
anyone wants one ask Davis and I'm sure
he can get that for you
okay uh okay committee drawers on the
other side of those lights right there
are committee drawers all of your names
are on those the keys are inside so if
you want to keep whatever you want to
keep in there
um I'm sure it's
secure uh and then um you can use that I
I don't tend to use it but they're there
if you need it I'm sorry sir and can you
awesome well welcome thank
you
um okay so emergency procedures I don't
anticipate any emergencies but uh uh
representative labry is our sort of
Sergeant arms and he's got code words if
something happens he knows what to do if
there's a fire our fire exit is
literally right there so you go out here
make a left and go down the stairs um so
hopefully that doesn't happen um but
that's that's the
procedures
um okay so I did 30 years in the Army
and what they taught you is when you
when you start off
an operation you read the mission so if
you can bear with me I'm just going to
read our mission and that way it it puts
it in record okay so it shall be the
duty of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative service to
consider all matters relating to labor
wages and workers compensation including
unemployment compensation and incentiv
incentive programs collective bargaining
and binding arbitration matters relating
to job retaining and employ
rehabilitative services and other
matters relating to balancing the rights
of employees to the needs of the
industrial sector and such other matters
as referred to um so that's what we're
here for and I'm really looking forward
to getting after that and understanding
the details and second and third order
consequences and the details of the
legislation that comes before
us uh partisan balance um
we're at a 9 and 11 uh the one thing is
on exec sessions it's a 24-hour
notification and so we can get a
replacement to vote only uh as directed
by the party
chair uh but we need 24 hours notice and
so please adhere to that um especially
if we have critical legislation where
it's going to be along a party
we are looking at our early bills that I
know of next week those are all the
financial ones and so we're going to
knock that out next week and we'll be
well ahead of well ahead of schedule I
didn't see any others on there that were
second
committee so I think I think we're good
on
that
BS no that's great thank you no that's
perfect um so subcommittees as as I
understand we have no standing
subcommittees okay subcommittee is an
instance where um something needs a
little bit more work
or something needs some more specific
research and we do that in
committee without passing a bill to send
that to the speaker and we just
got talked to again there are there are
over 200 commissions and committees
right now
300 okay he used 200 this morning it
could be 300 I don't know it's a boat
ton okay each one of those requires
whatever the bill says three five
representatives to fill that commission
and when you multiply that by two or 300
it's a ton of people and so uh what I
found to be very successful in my last
two committees was the use of a
subcommittee so we may consider the use
of a
subcommittee uh that is wholly within
the purview of this committee and then
that way if there's a subject that comes
up that um we need a little bit more
detail refinement to we just take that
on ourselves rather than pushing it back
on the rest of the house and that's just
for consideration and we can do that if
if that's what we determine is a better
way to do
it um so in terms of
of committee duties really in my mind as
a as a chair as a vice chair as the
clerk you have specific duties and and
we know what those are but our duties as
Representatives is to listen and hear
what people are saying it is to ask
questions that are pertinent to what
that person's expertise is that provide
value to our decision making and so um
be here be
present uh engage with the people
providing
testimony
um specifically
as a member you're not giving a speech
you're not engaging in a debate you're
not this is not a court of law so
there's no one there's no Perry masons
in here but it is about trying to
understand the issues and the second and
third order effects of of whatever
legislation is out there um so it's
really it's an exciting opportunity uh
that we have as committee members
and that anything else from anyone on
yeah it's a great Point uh and we'll
just we'll jump to that here real quick
so um typically in executive session uh
representative San I will talk
beforehand to sort of get a feel for you
know how things are going but uh it's
it's always good to understand who's
going to make the motion On Any Given
Bill and we'll decide that beforehand
and so when we go into executive session
understanding who's going to provide
that motion the person that provides
that motion
uh is responsible for the committee
report the
blurb and uh if there's a if there is a
minority um opinion as well then uh
either myself or representative Solon
will determine who uh writes that
Minority
position um you in the house calendar
you'll often times
see uh blurbs committee reports that are
a page long
um to me that's interesting but it's not
compelling um and
so um typically it's about understanding
the what the Crux of the matter is
expressing that efficiently and then uh
making sure that everyone understands
why either you agree or disagree with uh
what the committee has recommended and
so that is a great opportunity to engage
with house leadership to have an
opportunity to speak on the floor and um
you know we'll we'll figure out who does
that as we go through in terms of how
the executive sessions go are there
questions to that any comments anything
I
missed
okay
um so on decorum you know quite honestly
uh just treat people with respect and
dignity that that's what this is um the
assumption is that the person that's
providing testimony is uh is giving you
their best guess what they know and
they're not trying to be evasive or or
uh deception or deceitful um and so just
treat people with resp respect and
identity it's the same with us we're all
elected officials we're all uh adults
and uh so um just treat each other as
you would expect to be Tre treated and I
think I think we'll be
fine
sure thank you Mr chairman um I know
that through the years that I've been
here um 90 to 95% of what we discuss is
non-political and we've always left the
poit politics at the door that's been
the way it's been uh for years um
obviously there's going to be some bills
that both sides are passionate on um
that's the only time that I've seen
partisan Antics in this room so I just
want to say uh and thank everybody for
that I I agree completely uh tomorrow um
the last bill that we hear I'm actually
introducing and so as the one
introducing the bill I am not allowed to
sit on the uh in the committee uh so
Deputy will take over for for that bill
if you have a bill that's being
introduced to committee um you and you
uh
and you're the one that that uh enters
that bill into testimony then uh you
cannot sit on the committee you can vote
during executive session but you cannot
question okay that's just that's the
house rules and it's pretty
straightforward um on Executive
session uh we and we'll have our first
one
tomorrow essentially it has to be on the
on the house calendar so if you look at
our calendars I've got a standard blurb
in there that says we may exec bills uh
again as I said
initially the intention is and without
agreement from both sides we will not
accept bills that that aren't on the
calendar okay
um but essentially the a motion is made
and then
discussion and then when discussion is
done uh and then we vote and and we go
from there um in terms of committee
meeting you
know you don't have to ask every
question so you are more than welcome to
ask questions and I'm not going to keep
you from asking questions but we all
sort of hold each other accountable if
the same question's been asked 54 times
and I've seen this then someone else
asked the same question wait you just
asked that question so in my hand I
don't say that but in my hand i'm come
on now you know let's be courteous to
each other
um and so if it's a gerain question if
you if you're compelled to ask it by all
means but if you're not compelled to do
it and it doesn't provide value then
consider not asking the question and I'm
just trying
to make sure it's more efficient than
asking the same questions
or questions that don't don't
matter uh anything else on Executive
sessions that people want to bring up
we'll I'm sure we'll learn how to do it
straightforward we talked about absences
we talked about
email talked about dress food coffee
these are just the details of things we
talked
subcommittees so today we have um the
11: and then
um we have the employment security uh
folks coming in and they're they're just
going to
provide uh an example of what kind of
testimony we expect how what are the
critical issues from their perspective
and how do we engage with them okay so
that's that's later on
today uh here's um Davis Allen's phone
number right here representative Granger
page one thing that that comes up
occasionally is that people will want to
wear
um political t-shirts or something like
that and that's just a non-starter we we
that
yes so all questions go through the
chair and so it's not your own personal
dialogue with the person providing
testimony if you ask a question and you
want a followup then ask permission for
a followup I I will almost always
guarantee you that you'll get that
permission but it adds just that's the
process in committee we'll address
ourselves by
representative um and and that just
keeps that sort of level of
formality
uh a lot of people will email us
their testimony that's great um but the
clerk will collect the testimony and I
will ask anyone providing testimony to
give written copies to everyone and uh
you can do what you want with those um a
lot of times it does help to read their
testimony beforehand so you can sort of
frame your question repres I have a
question about the email system here
I've been out for a couple years is it
still the case where the whole committee
has one email address like house flavor
at whatever and it goes to all us
automatically is that still a thing yeah
you can get to that and I have gotten to
it if you ask me today to get it for you
I might be able to find it if it's still
out there and Jamie knows how to do that
okay the other thing is the email that
I've sent to all of you has all 20 of us
on it sure individually you it has all
of us on individually you could reply
all and change the subject yeah or copy
and paste it but did it is on the nh.gov
somewhere somewhere thanks I've done it
before but representative
Granger thank you Mr Mr chair so if if
you're looking for the shorthand version
of emailing everyone on the committee if
you log into Outlook and search for the
commit or and start typing it'll show up
and then if you need the individual
emails click the little puss button next
to it and it'll expand it but within the
Outlook within our system we just start
typing House labor labor it'll autop
populate y I've done that in the past
there you go thanks thank
you I knew the young guys the
Millennials would know the answer of
that um and so voting uh is is pretty
straightforward I'll ask the the clerk
to conduct a uh a roll call and it's a
roll call vote it'll be the same order
every time you know straight straight
off of the uh straight off the committee
last
um for those of you oh so here's another
thing that that I've done in my last two
committees I don't know that it's
necessary in this one but is field trips
so if there's something that we're
stumbling on that we think that a
firsthand knowledge would be a better
way to understand it let me know I'm
completely open to doing it uh I've done
it to on Ena we went to um the landfills
which is a huge bill a lot of a lot of
issues and that was very helpful and
then
yes
welcome you you got here just in time
for closing
remarks C can you introduce yourself
please um yeah my name is Kathy stab and
I represent um Hillsboro uh
which is um um W five in
Manchester sorry I'm late no welcome to
the committee thank
you okay any any aliis anything that we
didn't talk about that we need to talk
about burning questions not so burning
questions anything that I missed from
folks that have been here for a while
sir uh Mr chairman we have uh assigned
to us a staff person yes um so it's
always been unclear to me um
what what we can ask of them uh how we
ask I know we have to go through the
chair to ask questions but there are
many times when they probably could put
their hands on things that quicker than
we could given the the resources that
they have available to them so yeah it's
an it's a a resource for the committee
but my experience has been we haven't
really as a committee person really used
them a whole lot yeah so we talked to
Davis earlier um Davis Allen is our
researcher and Jamie Wyman is our house
Clerk or our assistant okay so Jamie
does all the scheduling she does the
room setup and she does sort of the
admin activities she'll she turns in the
paperwork that type of stuff um if you
have anything to do with that contact
Jamie you could do it yourself just
please let me know so that I have an
understanding of what she's doing she
has six different committees that she
supports um so we don't want to
overwhelm her but you're more than
welcome the other person we have is
Davis Allen he's new he's out of the
labor
department uh nice energetic kid just
ready ready to go um if you have
questions if you need rsas if you need
uh you know former house for example I
asked him to give me the blurbs for the
last year and the votes for the last
year and he gave me that within 24 hours
um so if you need something again you
can contact him directly his number is
in in this packet I gave you um but
please let me know so again I I I don't
want to overwhelm him if all 20 of us go
to him then that can be problematic um
but you feel free if you have questions
or you need uh historical data anything
like that he's he's anxious to
help thank you and I let me just also
mention that uh for those who are people
who are interested in the history of
legislation many times we get the same
bill com in here uh I I've been over to
the archives and much of that I think is
really underutilized the archives yeah
but if you ever want to know the history
of of legislation or why something ended
up in in the bill you can actually uh go
on the archives now a lot of it has been
digitized and you can look at all the
testimony for all the
legislation uh and it's been it's really
help ful especially when you're looking
to determine you know what the intent
was of of the legislation so all of the
notes are in there and all the
testimonies is in there and it's a it's
a very easy thing to use and you can get
to it by way of the uh the State website
so I would those haven't used it I would
take advantage of it and which reminds
me so the reason that we use the
microphone especially in a small room
like this is that our our hearings are
all recorded and so they are are
archived and in fact uh you can look at
last year's hearings now I mean you know
through the through the NH
um uh General Court website um and so
when when you do talk use your
microphones because that's this speaker
goes straight into the video um audio
recording and uh so a lot of times uh
you know at over across the street
they'll be watching the
testimony um and anyone any citizen can
watch the testimony and so that that's
the way that we make sure the audio is
is available to them is through the
microphones okay what else any other
questions
comments so let's take a 19 minute break
be back here at 11: and ready for the
the labor department to give their
you
e
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to listen um we're going to have
some guests here from the Department of
Labor and uh ma'am if you want to join
us and both of you can come up and
introduce yourselves and uh talk about
what the great Department of Labor
does sir forgive me Mr chair but I was I
was in another committee this morning so
I missed the orientation and I don't
want to be rude to my good friends from
the Department of Labor but I wanted to
introduce myself please uh represented
Michael kahill from New Market and I've
it's been my tradition since this is my
seventh term and I just wanted to let
the new members and returning members be
you know be aware that this is the best
committee you're lucky to be here very
good thank you sir for your Indulgence
thank you representative kill I'm glad
all right I'm not the most Savvy with
the technology so I'm glad I was able to
get that started good morning I'm
Danielle Albert I am the Deputy
Commissioner at the Department of Labor
very happy to be here today I'm here
with our general counsel Attorney John
garrian um we appreciate you having us
in and my understanding is maybe uh for
some of you a little bit of an overview
about what the Department of Labor does
um could be of some benefit um as well
as maybe some information or overview
about how we are available to assist um
the the committee and then any questions
that you may have um so just kind of
globally you know the Department of
Labor what is it what does it do uh you
know the Department of Labor is
primarily involved in the reg um in in
sort of four regulatory areas the two
largest ones I would say being the
regulation of what we call uh wage and
hour law it's a sector of labor law that
pertains to you know payment of wages
oversight of minimum wage payment to
employees how they're paid um youth
labor the employment of youth um hours
that youth work um those types of areas
it doesn't include unemployment
insurance that's a different agency uh
and I highlight that because there are
times I think when the um when New
Hampshire employment security who
oversees unemployment related issues is
confused with the Department of Labor um
so we don't handle any unemployment
insurance related issues but if an
employee is uh you know working for an
employer and there are issues related to
how that person's paid they're not
getting paid for all hours work the
means or modality of payment um that's
something that the Department of Labor
may get involved with uh and has some
oversight of um in addition the other
primary area that we're involved with
and I would say it's probably the
largest portion of what the department
um is involved with is regulation of the
workers compensation system for the
State of New Hampshire um so it is not
regulation of how policies are put
together that's the department of
insurance but employers are required to
secure and maintain workers compensation
insurance coverage to cover their
employees which is something that the
Department of Labor uh compliance wise
assures employers are doing and then if
there are disputes or issues related to
the payment of workers compensation
benefits to Injured Workers that's
something that the department of labor
would be directly involved in regulating
assisting with Andor overseeing uh so
oversight of the workers compensation
system is a large portion of what we do
um other things that the department is
involved with um the oversight and
regulation of uh Public Employee safety
so public employers your T the state
towns municipalities uh safety
regulations and safety requirements that
pertain to those employees is something
that the Department of Labor is employ
uh involved with uh and then also
interestingly enough the oversight and
regulation of boiler and elevator
certification uh so when you go you know
even in this building if you go into the
elevator you'll see the certificate
that's certifying your elevator to
operate that's something that's overseen
and actually issued by the Department of
Labor and we do it for again both uh
boilers and air tanks and pressure
vessels uh and all of the elevators in
the state um so in addition to
regulating those areas um I think it's
good to be aware the department has a
hearings Bureau so you know certain
types of disputes that may come forward
and primarily in the context of
employees who are asserting that their
owed wages uh from an employer they can
bring a claim through the department and
have an administrative hearing to get a
a determination or or resolution to that
claim we have a hearings Bureau with uh
hearings adjudicators who handle those
cases and render those decisions and
then disputed workers compensation cases
if a injured worker is having a dispute
with an insurance carrier about whether
or not a a injury is a compensable one
or the payment of certain benefits
attendant to or associated with a
compensable claim can be brought to the
Department of Labor through the hearings
Bureau where a a neutral adjudicator
separate from the regulatory divisions
is going to hear the case taken evidence
and then render a decision and then
there are appeal rights to either
various boards or to uh Superior Court
if for any party who is AG grieved by
any outcome that comes from our hearings
um from our hearings Bureau um that's a
little bit about what we do um quick in
a nutshell are there any questions that
I can take about what we're involved
with or uh anything about what we do at
the
department represent McKenzie you have a
question I do thank you good
um you um uh also helped uh Injured
Workers through a process internally
that was actually built into the law the
omnius yes person so can you talk a
little bit about the role of uh so that
people can come to the department they
can do prosay if they want to and there
was actually somebody to help them
within the department yeah absolutely so
the um provision that you're talking
about is a portion of our workers
compensation statute I want to say it's
at 281a 42c don't quote me on that um
what that section of the workers
compensation statute does is it
establishes a pray dispute resolution
coordinator which is a specific position
uh that by law is assigned to work with
unrepresented Injured Workers to assist
them in both understanding and then
navigating their rights within the
workers compensation system um so you
know that person is not an attorney and
the law is very clear clear the position
does not give legal advice and the
position cannot attend disputed hearings
with an injured worker but providing
information about the hearing process um
providing information about benefits or
how they work or what the you know
statute says about time frames related
to those benefits um sometimes this
position um which is currently filled at
the department uh sometimes helps
connect insurance carriers and Injured
Workers um we find um that there is a
fair amount of times when there are what
we call mised connections an injured
worker for whatever reason is having
difficulty getting a hold of their
adjuster they keep missing each other
they simply need to be connected to
resolve um either a bill or or uh
Indemnity payment cash payments that are
related to the claim trying to
facilitate those Communications to
resolve those types of issues before
they brew into disputes that may
ultimately end up going to a hearing um
so we do have a full-time position at
the department dedicated to working with
those individuals it's a resource that's
available to any unrepresented injured
worker certainly if the injured worker
um has an attorney and they have a right
to secure one if they like they're not
required to um and and we have plenty of
unrepresented Injured Workers who are
able to navigate the system including
the hearing process independently but
that position is uh solely dedicated to
working with those individuals to help
them really understand how workers
compensation works and and uh how how to
system and representative flon thank you
Mr chair it's good to see you again good
to see you as well um the question that
representative McKenzie proposed uh
became became law when the ability to
have an utsman if I could use that term
was it a few years ago no it's been in
the statute for some time although I
will admit I don't know exactly when the
provision went off the top of my head
into statute because I I always and when
former chairman infantine was there we
we and I discussed a number of times
about you know it's so hard to navigate
things when it's an issue about you know
unemployment or in this case you know
Injured Workers workers comper related
things and so how you don't know exactly
how long but it's been around for a
little while huh it it's the it's been
in statute for for some time and forgive
me because I don't know off the top of
my head when that particular provision
went into effect I will say that the
department um did take a look at the uh
statutory requirement and at the way we
had the role configured several years
ago maybe three four years ago now uh if
I'm if I'm my memory serves correctly
and we did refine how we were providing
that service in the sense that we had
several people previously providing the
same type of service but also handling
other areas within the system um and we
determined and then implemented that it
would be best to have a sole person
dedicated to only serving as that
coordinator so for the past three or
four years it's been that a singular
staff person providing that particular
service to Injured Workers um
alone please thank you Mr chairman um
that that position is probably very
unique and applicable for smaller claims
like a couple thousand dollars wor of
medical bills or something like that
because a a lawyer may not want to get
involved when it's a couple thousand
dollars because I think it's is it still
capped at a 20% fee or something
attorney's fees dependent on what stage
in the process you're in it's a little
different if you're at the appeals level
but attorney fees for Indemnity is going
to be at 20% if there's a medical bill
dispute dependent upon prevailing then
the insurance carrier May pay is St
limitation on claims to bring a claim
forward you have 18 months from the date
of a denial to assert the claim how
about from the date of the injury from
the date of the injury I believe they uh
Injured Workers have three years in
which to bring the claim forward my
apologies I should have asked for a
followup thank you sir and
representative sto thank you Mr chair um
I have a question about um about um data
regarding wages in the state on you know
uh the elmi gives average wages for
different types of employment but I'm
wondering if it's possible to get data
for how many people there are at each
wage level and what types of jobs
they're doing so for example the
question that we often get is how many
people are actually making minimum wage
or 725 an hour we know that there are
about a thousand people in the state um
is it possible to find out what they're
doing for work or is it because it's
such a small number it wouldn't be you
know it it would be specified it's an
excellent question uh and it's probably
one that would be better answered
through New Hampshire employment
security so wage reporting um and
Reporting you know how many employees
you're paying and and information
Associated to those payments uh I
believe goes over to Employment Security
uh in the context of their regulation of
the unemployment insurance um Provisions
um the Department of Labor will engage
with employees and employers and in the
course of performing an audit of or
inspecting an employer may look at
payroll records and ascertain or
determine somebody who should be making
minimum wage has not been and then we
may um you know ask that wages be
adjusted by that employer to make that
employee whole but as far as employers
reporting that type of information to
the Department of Labor we do not
receive that type of information I
believe it would be Employment Security
though you're welcome
thank you representative K thank you Mr
chair thank you Deputy would you like to
touch on the Inspection Division I'm
sorry would you like to touch on the
Inspection Division sure yes absolutely
so um our two primary divisions our
biggest divisions Our Workers
Compensation Division and then what we
also call the Inspection Division um
sometimes called wage and hour division
uh but inspections encompasses a little
bit more than just wage and hour so um
as it relates to sort of wage and hour
types of cases um we have a team of
inspectors overseen by a division
administrator who will go out and
normally upon receiving complaints when
employee is not bared or precluded from
contacting the department and asserting
I'm working for an employer that
employer hasn't paid me or they're
taking deductions out of my paycheck or
asserting some you know some sort of
complaint that they may have the
complaint is vetted and if if you know
once vetted the Inspection Division may
go out and engage with the employer the
course of a labor inspection in looking
at uh or to determine whether or not the
wage and hour labor laws are being
complied with uh and that typically
involves speaking with the employer um
there are employee interviews that can
happen those are confidential by Statute
um as well as looking at payroll records
or other types of records that the
employer maintains uh and then if there
are determinations or findings that
there have been violations of certain
labor laws some violations by a statute
are subject to a warning and if a
warning is given um the employer has 30
days to mitigate and correct and it
stays as a warning um some violations
primarily ones related to non-payment of
wages are not subject to a warning um if
a violation is cited then there is a uh
there may be a civil penalty or is a
civil penalty that can be at issue at
the conclusion of a of a labor
inspection um the labor inspector does
author a report that report will outline
what you know what their findings were
what the determination are um and then
there's a sit down meeting with the
employer where the report is given it is
discussed and the employer has uh the
option if penalties are at issue as the
result of one of those inspections has
the option to sit down and engage with
the Inspection Division director um to
you know sort through whether or not
it's something that can be resolved uh
or or um settled we call it an informal
process um so typically what the
department is looking for through that
processes has the employer adjusted some
of their practices or corrected
violations that they found and if so if
penalties are at issue they may be
reduced um reduced Down based on on
those types of um demonstrations thank
you very much you're
San thank you Mr chairman um could you
touch on one of my favorite topics um
public sector worker safety and the role
the department plays in that yes um so
as I had uh noted a moment ago the
inspection division is not just limited
to wage and hour inspections uh we also
have within that division what we call
our safety uh inspection unit or area um
so the department through RSA 277 and
certain aspects of the workers
compensation statute um oversees and
regulates uh primarily public employer
safety so as it relates to public
employer safety there is a you know a
statute that sets forth certain safety
requirements that apply to public
employees certain requirements that
employers are required to uh put into
place to assure that their employees are
safe um it it's OSHA regulates uh
through the federal government regulates
the private sector uh in New Hampshire
OSHA does not regulate your towns your
municipalities the state the the public
sector so that's left to the Department
of Labor um so through the statutes and
through the Department's regulations uh
we will go out and we will engage and en
assure that you know public employers um
are providing you know adequate safety
for their employ emplo es that is also
done through the course of an inspection
where a safety inspector goes out
engages with the public employer and is
performing like a workplace um audit uh
or or inspection of of the workplace and
employee safety and in addition to that
there are certain requirements set forth
through the workers compensation statute
that apply to all employers public and
private specifically related to filing
um safety summary forms and having joint
Loss Management committees in place uh
those are um requirements that as part
of the workers compensation statute are
supposed to assure that there are safe
workplaces mitigate the amount of
injuries that are happening um and our
safety inspectors will also go out and
engage with all employers uh to assure
that if required to have those have a
jlmc and safety summary forms on file
that those pieces have been attended
to you're
welcome any other
questions so I do have I do have a
question sure um regarding your
testimony and how do you interact with
the committee and what's the best way to
interact with the
committee um so the department if I
understand the question correctly um
you're asking about when the department
comes to public hearings and how do we
best engage so um we do Monitor and
follow legislation so I'll I'll start
with saying that certainly we are a
resource um you know I take a lot of
Pride I believe commissioner Maryfield
who's the commissioner of Labor takes a
lot of pride um in that we are a
resource not only for employers
employees insurance carriers um but for
you as well so when questions come up um
we are happy to answer them as it
relates to uh public hearings uh you
know we primarily are going to be um
offering technical guidance so if we
have reviewed leg um proposed
legislation and we have some technical
guidance to provide some maybe
conflicting with another area of Statute
that we think it's important to be aware
of um or um something that we might not
be able to administer we would want to
make certain that you're aware of that
that if we see complications or problems
in administering it for some reason that
we've shared that uh you know we don't
view our role as as um policy it's not
it's not what we're involved with so
giving policy guidance is not how we
conceptualize our role but providing
that tech technical guidance about
whether or not the proposed requirements
uh can be implemented regulated or work
with existing law um is how is how we
will approach um uh coming to public
hearings certainly any questions you
have we will do the best of our
abilities to answer we may not know on
the spot off the top of our heads uh you
know the exact answer but we will always
follow up uh if it's something that you
do need to know and again if questions
come up ahead of public hearings we're
always happy uh to engage in or answer
what we
can and the one thing you didn't mention
that it's not necessarily the purview of
this committee as this is a policy
committee but also the financial impact
uh going forward in terms of any
legislation that's going to have a
financial impact do you do you provide
that information as well yes we do um we
will provide it one when asked when
fiscal notes are provided to us if we've
assessed that there's a financial impact
we'll provide that information that way
as well as uh raise it during public
testimony um if there's not a a
financial impact um we're happy to share
or answer questions about whether or not
there's a concern about financial impact
but yes our Our Testimony
could include uh whether or not there's
a financial impact to any proposed
legislation
okay um and so do you find normally that
you at the end of your your testimony
you you're neutral or do you actually
come out in favor or oppose to given
bills I've seen different departments do
it different ways that's why I asked the
question yeah no it's an excellent
question um and thank you for asking it
by by and large the department is
neutral on bills again we conceptualize
our Ro role is providing the technical
guidance uh you know can we implement
the the proposed requirements do we see
technical suggestions to how either to
make language more clear uh if there's
conflict with other areas of law that
should be that that you should be made
aware of but we uh do not typically take
a position in favor of or not in suppor
of bills okay great anything we missed
any other questions comments H there you
are I'm sorry hidden on my right side
thank you Mr chairman um who is going to
be representing um Department of Labor
at our hearings it's an excellent
question it um I believe for the session
it will be attorney garrian and or
welcome all right well thank you so much
for coming I appreciate it and uh look
forward to a great session it is our
pleasure thank you very much for having
us and please don't hesitate to reach
out if you do need anything absolutely
much all right so we have five minutes
uh until Employment Security gets here
and uh is he here okay so we can go
ahead and oh there he goes okay oh my
gosh
yeah we're good if you're if you're okay
you a that's great as long as everyone
has room to put it
yours rep Ranger are you going to see uh
time oh beautiful thank you I appreciate
that if you want to give it to him then
okay I
more
okay all right sir all right uh please
introduce yourself we'll be going Page
by Page through all of this material
your Vice chairman has probably told you
that's how I usually do the orientation
here for employment we blocked off the
rest of the day just for
that um uh for the record Richard lver
is Deputy Commissioner with the New
Hampshire Department of Employment
Security so um some materials that I
brought just so folks have the most
upto-date versions you if you've been on
the labor Committee in the past you've
you know received a copy of our law and
rule book and some other materials so I
brought copies U updated copies for
everyone so what has not been
distributed around and I'll leave for
folks to take a copy is our current
version of 282a and all of the relevant
rules to 282a so any uh legislation
that's impacting the unemployment
program the statute and the rules are
all right here for folks so um you can
uh grab yourself a copy of that those
are the heavy ones to bring back to my
car um I also brought a copy of what
individuals
that are newly filing for unemployment
when they come in for their mandated
session to get the dos and don'ts for
utilizing the unemployment program this
is what they receive when they come in
for their one-hour session with our
staff in the New Hampshire Works offices
throughout the state um so I thought
it'd be helpful uh for members to see
that um the pamphlet with the word
scramble on the front is a description
of all of our programs both the
unemployment program but also all of the
uh Reemployment programs that we have
for both individuals and for
employers and then the uh thinnest
handout um was is just a uh uh some
information that I present to employers
when I go out to talk to them about
programs that we have to help with
Recruitment and Retention so um I also
have I brought uh uh business cards so
everyone will have my contact
information as well and I'll make sure
to hand those out for folks uh looking
around the faces some of you know where
to find me and know know where I am at
all times it seems so uh for those who
won't be a problem um but just quick
overview of the department and then more
than happy to answer any and all
questions that members might have so
Employment Security is made up of three
bureaus um the first Bureau the
unemployment compens Bureau the one that
is uh the most um uh popular uh for uh a
topic to be addressed in this committee
um that is um with the Department's
responsibility to administer the
Unemployment Compensation Program for
the state so we uh collect taxes and
wage reports from employers those taxes
that are paid by employers go into the
state's trust fund that is managed by
empy Employment Security and uh the only
uh payments that are going into there
are from New Hampshire employers and
then the only reason to take dollars out
of that trust fund is to pay
unemployment benefits to eligible
individuals we um um we receive those
applications for benefits we determine
eligibility and um as unemployment is a
week toe eligibility based program we
then um receive the those weekly
applications determined weekly
eligibility um and provide those
payments to what uh the weekly benefit
amount that the individual qualifies for
so that is our largest program that we
administer uh we have two other bureaus
we have the Reemployment Services Bureau
so that is U the public uh front-facing
offices that um folks have either in or
very close to their districts we have 12
New Hampshire Works offices we manage
all of those offices um and they are
located throughout the state to try to
Pro provide as much convenience to not
only the claim filing public for people
utilizing the unemployment program but
also for employ employers to utilize for
recruitment um and uh for individuals
who don't need to be filing for
unemployment but are searching for a new
job or a better job they can utilize the
resources that we have available in
those offices um and we administer a
whole assortment of training programs
out of those locations as well um our
third Bureau is the uh labor market and
information Bureau so those are the the
uh State's team of economists and labor
market analysts who work hand inand with
the Federal Bureau of Labor Statistics
and they are responsible for publishing
and disseminating labor market
information uh the most uh um uh common
that folks are familiar with would be
the monthly unemployment rate in the
labor force uh but they are also
publishing um U all sorts of materials
throughout the year dealing with
occupational projections uh industry
projections uh industry demand and
occupational demand so a lot that they
uh review and analyze and publish
throughout the year so all three of
those bureaus are all housed within
Employment Security so that's just a
general overview um happy to
get into um any uh additional detail or
answer any questions um that folks have
um and um have as much time as you
need excellent thank you any
questions representative
flan nice to see you representative
please
um the unemployment situation in the
state we're very low unemployment
correct correct correct uh we're lowest
in the Northeast at
22% uh Federal unemployment's at 4.1% so
lowest in the Northeast and or second
lowest in the Northeast Vermont is
usually about a tenth per lower uh but
we're about third to Fourth lowest in
the
country follow up Mr
chairman yes sir
um how do I say
this our employers
like starve for for new employees and
other is there like a glut of jobs still
out there in New Hampshire that
employers are trying to fill uh demand
is still elevated not quite as elevated
as we saw um initially coming out of the
pandemic okay uh but we do a um we
publish it every other month uh but it's
a job demand report where we actually um
we subscribe to a service that um uh
Combs through all of the job postings
for New Hampshire based employment um or
people looking for um individuals in New
Hampshire uh for employment um and we
break those down by industry by
occupation we look at what employers are
posting uh we look at what skills
they're identifying and the number of
postings is higher right now than it was
in 2019 to give you that pre-pandemic
comparison
uh but not quite as elevated as it had
been um the most current data from the
labor market Bureau when we were um
we're talking with house Ways and Means
last week and um New Hampshire is at
full employment right now um when you
look at U uh I think uh director gotab
Brian golab's our director of our labor
market information Bureau his favorite
uh uh measuring stick for whether a
state is at full employment is the
employment population ratio so that
measure that looks at individuals that
are 25 to 54 years old Prime working
years and anytime New Hampshire is at
85% of individuals in that group working
um historically he considers that to be
full employment New Hampshire is just
above that right now um between I think
we're at
85.4% so tight labor market
um we've seen about an increase when we
look at private sector jobs in the state
we have about 25,000 more private sector
jobs now than we did prior to the
pandemic so we've seen overall Topline
growth of close to 5% but it has not
been anywhere um close to being evenly
distributed across all of your sectors
and employer types so we continue to see
strong growth uh within the professional
technical scientific indust indry so um
there's a lot going on there it's a
pretty diverse um employment sector we
need workers so we need workers there
healthc care is where uh you know we we
see a lot of growth in professional
Technical and scientific um where we
haven't seen as much growth is in the
health care side particularly hospitals
long-term care um a lot of the
occupational demand is registered nurses
lnas LPNs um so still probably the
highest demand occupation is nursing
just so happens that that registered
nurses are your largest occupation in
healthcare so that's where most of your
now represa kill thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr labers for taking my
question uh can you tell me how many New
work you must have been spying on me
before right before I came over um so
the most recent commuter data that we
have so New Hampshire has about 130,000
residents that commute out of the state
uh to work about 100,000 of them leave
to go to
Massachusetts um however we also have
about 880,000 people that commute into
New Hampshire every day to work so
that's a net loss of about 50,000 uh we
Lo that the loss is with Massachusetts
so Massachusetts you get the 100,000 New
Hampshire residents that leave to work
in Mass Metts mostly in the the Southern
Tier counties and then we have about
60,000 that come in from Massachusetts
to work in New Hampshire um we are uh
net positive with regard to Maine and
Vermont so there are more residents of
Maine and Vermont that commute into New
Hampshire to work uh compared to New
Hampshire residents that commute out to
work in either Maine or Vermont but
about 130,000 New Hampshire residents
leave every day to work and about 80,000
out of state residents commute into New
Hampshire every day to work thanks very
much good question thank you represent
stop thank you um I just um asked the
Department of Labor this question um the
um
elmi
reports um um average wages in different
occupations um is it possible to get the
numbers of people who are employed at
different wage levels for example how
many people are making less than $15 an
hour the other question is we often hear
well how many people are actually making
725 an hour we've heard that it's about
a thousand um is there any way to find
out what kinds of occupations those are
um or is it like such a small number it
can't be
anonymized um so good good question we
did um the economic and labor market
information Bureau did put put out a
report looking at um minimum wage
earners in New Hampshire I can make I
can send out the link to that for the
full committee but if you um want to go
look at it right away if you go on um um
the nhes homepage so
nhes.nh.gov and you click on data and
statistics and as you scroll down you'll
see that the the minimum wage report is
one of the featured reports thank you um
that was done uh
I want to say two to three years ago um
with regard to what we have for um uh
wage data so we get uh so there's a
couple sources there one we get the
quarterly wage and tax reports from
employers um employers tell us everyone
who worked for them in W2 employment
during that quarter and they tell us
exactly how much they were paid um
during that quarter we don't know
whether they are full-time or part-time
we don't know what their hourly rate of
earnings is based on those records it's
very minimal amount of information that
we have so we all we get as um first
name last name social security number
and the amount that they earned um we
also get survey based data um through
Bureau Labor Statistics that does look
at occupational earnings and so the
occupational earnings the hourly rates
that you see in the Publications it's
it's um taken from the survey based data
um and that does break it down by
occupation um and it uh gives a sense of
you know which of those occupations are
projected to grow which are projected uh
to uh lose positions so it does have
some data there um the other source of
hourly
data we do take the tax and wage reports
from employers those uh reports are
coded by industry industry so we know
based upon the uh North American
industrial classification system or
nakes code we know whether you're a
healthcare employer or manufacturer
manufacturer or hospitality and we do
publish the average um earnings hourly
earnings for workers in each of those
sectors but it's sector-based not
occupational
based thank you thank you representative
KES thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I've been looking
at some statistical data of remote
positions do you guys have a kind of a
conduit to track that of how the remote
positions are in New Hampshire versus
others yeah so um what we have and what
we would like to have more of so most of
the because the filings from employers
don't include that type of information
we don't have administrative records
which say definitively how many remote
position
uh there are in New Hampshire but we do
have some survey based data um and we're
been looking to do more New Hampshire uh
employer surveys around that topic um so
hopefully that's something to come in
2025 the most recent data that uh I have
seen uh put New Hampshire up in the top
five states nationally for the the
number or percentage of employers that
indicate um the uh desire to continue to
have some level of remote um whether
that be limited remote or full remote um
but New Hampshire was uh uh I think
Colorado had the most uh the highest
percentage of employers looking to
continue to offer remote New Hampshire
at the second most in that survey and
that was a national survey and it was
about
35% of employers uh were looking to
continue to have um some level of remote
um about over 50% of jobs in New
Hampshire are in sectors that it's very
difficult to have remote um you think
about those uh Frontline um customer
facing uh type jobs um also
manufacturing uh construction Health
Care uh Hospitality so you know that
that's a little over 50% of our jobs uh
difficult to have much remote there but
most of the growth that I'd indicated in
professional technical scientific the
highest growing uh industry in terms of
number of jobs since the pandemic um
it's an industry that very much lends
itself to flexibilities with with
scheduling flexibilities of where you're
going to be working so it seems that's
what people are demanding and and kind
of voting with their feet intending to
go to jobs within that sector thank
you good represent
McKenzie thank you Mr chairman
um there there are a couple of questions
here that I think um kind of go together
so let me let me just ask this so the
absolutely yeah so the how is the system
funded so that people understand um you
know how this happens and what the
federal role would be uh and then just
give us a sense if you could we'll drill
more into this and we have a legislation
deals with increasing the rate but just
give a sense of like what the top rate
is and and that kind of stuff so funding
you know how you there's an
administrative feed that comes out of
the employer contributions and things
just because this is our first committee
and maybe the first introduction to
unemployment insurance for many people
yeah certainly representative so the the
unemployment system is 100% employer
funded um employers as I indicated
before they file that quarterly tax and
wage Report with the Department uh that
includes all of the employment that they
provided with the a very limited amount
of information on each employee and then
the employers pay based on their
experience-based tax rate um for the
wages that they paid out during that
quarter uh new states are similar in how
they assess unemployment taxes on
employers but not exact um so the there
are some ways that that is compared in
terms of unemployment tax burdens state
to state that I can talk about in New
Hampshire employers pay at their earned
rate uh on the first
$14,000 in annual earnings per employ
employee so a new employer in New
Hampshire starts at an earned rate of
2.7% um that 2.7% then is adjusted by
the solvency controls in our statute so
they are referred to as fund balance
reductions so when the unemployment fund
grows to levels approaching and
achieving solvency the fund balance
reductions reduce those rates and then
when the unemployment trust fund um
starts to fall below those solvency
amounts those those those discounts or
those fund balance reductions go away so
right now that a new that new employer
starts at 2.7% for their first year and
right now there is a fund balance
reduction of 1% so they pay it
1.7% on the first
$144,000 in annual wages per employee
now the average employer right now is
paying at about
6% per employee on those first $144,000
in annual wages so about $85 per
employee per year is what the current
rate is um that is about the lowest it's
been in the last 30 years um and lower
than it was prior to the
pandemic uh nationally when you compare
again um each state has a little bit of
a different way of calculating the
experience-based tax rate and also on
the what the taxable wage base is or
that 14,000 some states it's less some
states it's more uh when you just take
total taxes paid compared against W
total wages paid New Hampshire has the
third lowest unemployment tax burden in
the country currently lowest in the
Northeast uh Florida is the lowest uh
Mississippi is the second lowest and
then New Hampshire
at
6% um nationally that that uh um
unemployment tax burden uh New Hampshire
is about a third of the national average
and we're a third of what Massachusetts
uh requires of their their employers so
um on the revenue side it's completely
employer funded that all goes into the
unemployment trust fund that is managed
by Employment Security that trust fund
currently sits at about $390 million
those funds sit with the US Treasury
they do not sit in a bank account
managed um here in New Hampshire states
are required um to have those trust fund
dollars be in uh with US Treasury we
then draw down from that and deposit
into that on a daily basis through our
own locally managed accounts so we look
at what our demand is going to be for
benefit payments we draw that down um
each week so that we can make those
payments out of out of a local account
um and then as those tax dollars come in
they then immediately get deposited same
day they come in they go to that
Washington based account so uh 390
million that's the healthiest uh the the
New Hampshire's unemployment trust fund
has ever been um going into the pandemic
just to put it into perspective we were
at about $300
million um New Hampshire was fortunate
we did not have to borrow from the
federal government in order to pay
benefits during the pandemic a lot of
states did uh Massachusetts had to
borrow uh significantly in order to
continue to borrow to pay benefits
meaning they depleted their own trust
fund um New Hampshire did not have to do
that and by all measures right now uh
with the federal government they look at
they uh do a solvency report every year
of state's uh trust funds their
unemployment trust funds uh New
Hampshire is currently solvent um right
now I think we're we're above solvency
um just because of the years that they
take into consideration when they're um
evaluating solvency is they look at your
your three worst or highest benefit
payout years in the last 20 years well
one of those is the
pandemic um an outlier probably
shouldn't be factored in to that
calculation but it is still New
Hampshire is solvent um so employer paid
trust fund solvent um benefits going out
uh currently as uh representative
Flanigan had asked um uh about uh you
know low unemployment right now we have
about 32 to 3,300 individuals that are
collecting unemployment benefits on a on
a weekly basis uh we track that and
compare that to pre pandemic just to put
it into perspective we're slightly lower
than we were in 2019 when you look at
the same week uh we're running about 5
to 10% below volume that we had in 2019
which was a good labor market good
healthy economy uh Massachusetts kind
country as a whole are higher than they
were they're anywhere from 10 to 15%
higher than they were in uh 2019 same
week so New Hampshire lower volume of
unemployment claims right now um
nationally they're looking at a little
bit higher when you compare to
2019 when someone comes in and files for
unemployment um as I had indicated it's
you have to be initially eligible so you
have to be unemployed through no fault
of your own most common scenario there
is a layoff but there are volunt quit
scenarios that could trigger eligibility
based upon the circumstances of why
someone left employment um those are are
um much more likely to be determined
ineligible if you're quitting employment
um than being considered eligible but we
do have scenarios that you could be
eligible um when you come in we look at
make sure your separation was a
qualifying separation so you're
unemployed through no fault of your own
and then we look at your wages what you
had in your four quarter base period for
most people their four quarter base
period is the first four of the most
recently completed five calendar
quarters if you don't have enough wages
there we'll look at the most recent four
completed calendar quarters and you need
to have at least $2,800 in uh covered
employment so W2 earnings from a New
Hampshire employer and two quarters of
at least
1,400 in that base period in order to be
monetarily eligible for unemployment
benefits um right now in New Hampshire
your maximum weekly benefit amount is
$427 that benefit amount has been at
$427 since
2007 um in order to be eligible for that
you need to have earned at least
$41,500 in your four quarter base period
um if you come in right at that 415 that
wage replacement rate for what the
benefits that you'll receive of 427 what
that represents to the A the wages you
are earning it's about a
54% wage replacement rate um however
when you look at the average base period
earnings for individuals that are um
qualifying for that 427 right now the
average base period earnings that
they're receiving is about
$888,000 so individuals on average
qualifying for $427 a week had annual
earnings of
$888,000 so a wage replacement rate
that's more more down in the line of
around
30% um you need to demonstrate your
eligibility every week for which you are
unemployed you do that by filing um
online uh a weekly application where you
certify to being able to work available
to work and you're conducting an
adequate work search to show your
attachment to the labor market you're
out there um talking to hiring employers
you're preparing yourself uh to get back
to work
uh we we confirm that with your weekly
um um application and then for each week
that that occurs you could be paid that
weekly benefit amount uh for up to 26
weeks during your benefit year uh New
Hampshire does allow you to have
part-time work while you're collecting
uh so you're able to have part-time work
and you need to report that with your
earnings while you're collecting
unemployment um there is a a um
disregard for we do allow you to um earn
up to 30% of your weekly benefit amount
without it reducing your weekly benefit
amount and anything above that we then
reduce your weekly benefit amount dollar
for dooll with the earnings that you
receive um right now uh individuals are
eligible for up to that 26 weeks on
average they're filing for uh 12 and a
half weeks uh right now that has been
creeping up so um from the beginning of
2023 to where we are right now average
duration or the number of weeks that
people are filing for on average has
gone up about 2 and a half weeks um so
um we have been watching that slowly
increase still one of the lower um
average durations in the country uh New
Hampshire is usually in the uh uh top
five in terms of lowest duration um and
one of the lowest exhaustion rates so
number of people that use all 20 six
weeks of their benefits um right now I
think we're uh right around 17 uh% of
filers exhaust their benefits uh so
completely employer funded uh healthy
solvent trust fund of 390 million on the
benefit side uh weekly certifications
weekly eligibility determination and the
$427 that's a mouth
thank you great question represent
Warden yeah when you were talking
earlier about the unemployment rates
Statewide and such how do you how does
an Department account for people who are
$199
uh independent contractors I maybe even
that would include like an individual
proprietor like a plumber who works for
him or herself how do you account for
those people great question um so the
unemployment rate gets Direct derived
from the uh monthly survey conducted by
US Census and Bureau of Labor Statistics
so they do they they do a monthly survey
of about 1300 households in New
Hampshire and based upon the answers to
the questions that are asked that's what
then uh gets extrapolated out to
determine who uh the number of employed
the number of
unemployed uh generally if you're
working 1099 employment those earnings
do not get reported and do not get taxed
by the department so it's only your W2
um earnings that get reported and are
subject to the tax um but depending on
the households that are part of the
survey each month an individual that is
uh self-employed or working 1099 based
employment or gig employment um they
could be answering those questions in a
way that would um put them into the
employed group um and uh so I think you
get some of that uh self-employment 1099
based earnings will get captured in that
survey so again it's that survey that
determines our labor force number
determines the unemployment rate
different though than the administrative
records that get filed each quarter by
employers um and the the job numbers
that representative
Granger thank you Mr chair and thank
thank you for taking my question I have
a I have a couple questions here I
haven't been able to get the answer to
these I've done a little research but
are you aware of any private sector on
Employment Insurance options in the
state of New Hampshire or elsewhere in
the United
States um I'm aware of your bill uh I'm
not allowed to ask you later so I figure
I ask you now uh no I am not aware of
any uh uh private unemployment insurance
options um in New Hampshire or in other
states um it's worth asking that
question as well to the Department of
Insurance to the depart to the extent it
was an insurance product that would be
required to register with them but I'm
not aware of any private um unemployment
insurance options okay are are you aware
of any a followup please are you aware
of any uh federal or state law that
would make it impossible or illegal for
private sector unemployment insurance to
exist um again um I did prepare some
materials for the hearing on your bill
uh representative later on today uh I
think 2:30 is when it's being heard um
and um uh just to so you're not held in
suspense here um we did reach out as we
do uh we reach out to the US Department
of Labor with every bill that is filed
that uh proposes a change um or to do
anything to the Unemployment
Compensation Program because it is a
federal state partnership um and states
need to be in Conformity and compliance
with Federal requirements um for
employers to get a whole host of
benefits um so we did reach out to them
with a copy of your bill um and um while
they said they they do not generally
comment on bills that are not looking to
make a change as your bill looks to
create a study committee um they did say
that um and I'll I'll I'll I didn't
bring it with me now but I have it for
230 a copy of their response that said
if there were uh private insurance
options uh that could C problems for New
Hampshire employers so right now uh
because New Hampshire has an
unemployment program that meets Federal
requirements um and we're in compliance
and Conformity with Federal requirements
um two things happen as a result of that
one New Hampshire receives about uh $30
million in Grant Awards uh to implement
all sorts of programs the unemployment
program Reemployment Services programs
um and then we also have uh the benefit
for New Hampshire employers that they
get a uh reduction in their federal
unemployment tax of 90% as long as they
pay their state unemployment tax so
because New Hampshire is in compliance
with Federal requirements um considered
inconformity um New Hampshire employers
rather than paying 6% on that first
$14,000 in wages to employees um to the
feds for their their feuda or their
federal unemployment tax they pay uh 6%
so a 90% reduction that benefits to
Hampshire employers about $200 million
in tax savings per year uh because we
have a compliant Unemployment
Compensation Program so um if you were
to uh privatize that and it uh an
employer were not paying their state
unemployment tax um or the state did not
have eligibility um uh rules in place
for individuals collecting unemployment
that met those Federal requirements that
would be in Jeopardy so employers U
might be subject to their full feuda
their full federal unemployment tax um
and again the collectively for the whole
state that's about $200
million thank you very much okay and uh
representative Hall uh thank you Mr
chair are there any special
considerations for employers that have
no presence in New Hampshire other than
employees um another a good question
we've seen um a increase in
registrations for outof State entities
that have New Hampshire employment so um
where that comes up most right now is
individuals that are fully remote so I
live in New Hampshire and I work for a
Minnesota company um I never go out
there right I'm in New Hampshire 100% of
the time that Minnesota employer is
required to register in New Hampshire
and pay taxes on the wages paid to that
New Hampshire employee uh so we do have
you do see some of that particularly
coming out of the pandemic an increase
in the number of single employee or low
employee um employer registrations with
those out ofate employers so if the
employee is in New Hampshire um and
they're they're they're not um going out
to that uh other State's location
wherever the business might be primarily
located they need to reported in New
Hampshire and the taxes paid on the New
Hampshire uh to New Hampshire on the on
the
wages uh yeah please and do you have any
statistics numbers on how many employees
there are like that in the state um I
don't but that's something we can get uh
we can uh look at that most of that I do
know from having looked at it previously
a lot of that is in the um um the growth
within professional technical scientific
which that's where you have um uh
consult
um a lot of Professional Services so a
lot of some of that growth has been with
those single employee out of state
employers but we can get that we can get
that statistic for you great thank you
and one like one last question uh
representative
K thank you Mr chair I might have
two U thank Mr yes uh getting back to
the
1099 uh as as understand 1099 employees
are their wages are not filed not
there's not they're not paying in so
therefore normally they do not receive
uh benefits although that did happen
during covid and that was Federal money
I I yes correct yeah it was uh
eligibility was broadened by the feds
during the pandemic period and the
dollars that un um self-employed
individuals that were unable to conduct
their self-employment those were all
federally financed benefits small paid
by paid by Hampshire employment security
but federally financed small followup
small thank you and that also would be
in Jeopardy if we were to privatize the
emplo the unemployment insurance is that
correct um it's a good follow-up
question for uh US Department of Labor
but um I believe if we're not in
compliance I think that does jeopardize
the ability to participate in federal
programs normally that only occurs we're
only participating in federal benefit
programs during the uh times of an
economic downturn um you know pandemic
or Great Recession uh usually the feds
will come in they'll U increase benefits
they'll broaden eligibility they'll
increase the number of weeks uh so those
types of the ability to participate in
those could be jeopardized but again it
a lot it would largely depend on what
the parameters were for any uh private
unemployment insurance program tiny tiny
little question about uh about the
remote workers okay go okay I think this
could be a one word
response okay uh other the RO remote
workers in New Hampshire are there any
federal employees that are working
remote currently or as of
yesterday I am sure there are New
Hampshire has um rather than go off top
of Mind here let me tell you how many
federal employees we have
I was going to be close I was going to
say 8,000 we have about 9,000 federal
government employees in the state of New
Hampshire a lot of those are postal
carriers um and then um uh across all
other Federal departments but you have
9,000 um people in New Hampshire that
work for the federal government thank
you very much they might not be remote
right they they could be reporting to
their federal office in New Hampshire um
so I don't know how many are remote but
9,000 federal workers in New Hampshire
thank you and
representative thank you Mr chairman
good to see you again Mr labers um
couple things uh we talked about the
trust fund and the employer share um so
two questions with the Indulgence of the
chair please uh can you speak about the
administrative part of that and how
that's funded and the penalty phase if
the business is out of is out of phase
with credits and you know where I'm
going yes um all right uh so two things
there one the administrative portion of
that employer tax so um 282a does have a
provision that 410 of
1% of the quarterly tax paid paid by
employers is uh not put into the trust
fund it goes into the administrative
contribution fund um that money gets
used for two things one it go uh $6
million a year goes to the job training
fund so that uh fund pays for training
for individuals
uh who uh are um eligible for Medicaid
Medicaid expansion tanif or snap to help
them get back to work it also pays 50%
reimbursement to employers for their um
uh training cost that they have for
their um existing workers it also pays
for the Work Ready New Hampshire program
that's uh conducted on all the community
college system campuses with that uh job
Readiness uh free class that they
provide to New Hampshire residents um
the other portion of it goes to pay the
administrative um costs of the
department fill the Gap in that is left
by the inadequacy of the federal grants
that we get um and that uh basically uh
supports about uh we have 12 New
Hampshire Works offices the
administrative contribution uh supports
about six of those 12 so if we had to
rely on the federal dollars alone we'd
only be able to have six offices instead
of our 12
um the uh penalties on employers the
second question there so New Hampshire
we have three uh uh tax rate schedules
for employers uh the and this is all set
within
282a uh the first schedule is for um uh
positive rated employers positive rated
meaning that they have paid more in
taxes than we have paid out in
unemployment benefits to their former
employees those employers have the
lowest rates as they should they are the
least amount of risk to the Unemployment
Compensation Program then there is a
second table which is for uh newly
negative rated employers meaning that in
the last um year they um have gone from
being a positive rated employer where
they have paid more taxes in than we've
paid out in benefits to flipping that
where we have now paid out more benefits
to their former employ employes than
they have paid in taxes um so that
middle table for those newly negative
rated um it has a slightly higher rates
than for the positive rated employers
and then for any employer that is
negative rated for four years or more or
the the chronically negative rated
employers these are employers with
seasonal uh business patterns seasonal
layoffs uh those employers pay at table
three highest rates and they also have
penalties um on them um so when um other
New Hampshire employers positive rated
employers are getting those fund balance
reductions um and there's a whole I
could go into fund balance reductions
for we could spend all of lunch on it um
um for the negative rated employers they
have SE charges or penalties uh to make
up for their risk um and and and using
the unemployment program quite
frequently or release with their former
um C they laid off employees um so they
pay at higher rates and they have
penalties based upon the balance in the
trust
fund I think that covered it great
questions all
right excellent start thank you so much
for good questions thank you for your
testimony and uh we'll meet back here at
1 pm to start our first uh hearings and
if Republicans can hold tight real quick
I got about four and a half minutes
worth of stuff to talk talk about um
minutes
e
are you planning on introducing yes sir
okay we're
good this hearing will come to
order and the first hearing this
afternoon is House Bill
69 an act requiring businesses to use
the federal ever verify system of the
United States citizenship and
immigration
services to introduce the bill is
representative
saborin uh representative saborin D
schaner but that that's okay thank you
sir I got it yes sir Sabor and D Shire
yes sir sir the floor is yours thank you
so good afternoon representative
chairman Katon and members of the
committee I'm representative Sor D
schaner from Rockingham District 30 in
seabook today I'll be introducing HP 69
of which I'm a co-sponsor requiring
businesses to use the federal EV verify
system of the United States citizenship
and Immigration Services following
introduction of this bill I I do need to
go uh to my next committee I'm
introducing a bill which I'm the prime
sponsor of I'm just a co-sponsor here uh
will not be able to stay after that that
being said this is a pro-worker bill uh
the goal here is to formally adopt the
eify program as mandatory best practice
for our business Community uh this
program was passed federally by the
Clinton administration and is free for
businesses to use the more states that
participate the more accurate the
accounting uh this bill has been in
front of this committee before and it's
a frequent flyer so if any committee
members have any questions I do
encourage them to visit the program
website ever verify. goov does feature a
list of frequently asked questions uh
thank you all for your time and
consideration and there's looks like
there's plenty of other folks that wish
to testify as well okay do we have any
questions
please thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking question um just out of
curiosity with what we've seen with The
Changing of the Guard down in Washington
DC I would ask it is this bill really
necessary at this
point uh it's worth considering okay
thank you worth considering yeah cool
okay and that a technical question
uh how does the system work with people
with two-letter
names like if you're uh from Korea or
China or something of that nature where
you have a two-letter last name does the
does that system work um I don't want to
give any information I'm not totally
confident on Sir so I don't want to I
would suggest consult the the E verified
AG website on that matter okay yes sir
any other
questions all right sir thank you so
Wellington if you could just um state
your name and who you represent and then
we'd love to hear your testimony okay
thank you um representative kraton good
afternoon to the members of the
committee I'm Christine Wellington I'm
from Derry New Hampshire um I'm here as
an individual but as a member of the New
Hampshire imigrants rights Network I did
send out yesterday a letter um stating
our group's opposition to this bill um
the ever verify program has been around
for about 30 years it's remained
unpopular and not well used um some um
entities that have Federal contractors
are mandated to use it only 10 states in
the union mandate employers to use it
and even in those States it's ill and
underused um and there have been no
consequences for those employers it
doesn't seem to be something that's
business friendly much less employer
friendly um just to go back to the the
numbers um in the United States is's
approximately um 33 million employers or
businesses and there's only 1.3 million
employeers enrolled in the ever verifi
program in New Hampshire there's about
2600 employers enrolled in this program
but there's almost 40,000 businesses by
the um data that I was able to pull out
um there are costs and pitfalls to
employers especially the smallest
employers that don't have um HR uh
companies and mechanisms to handle this
um and the US Department of Justice in
the past has brought lawsuits against um
employers that have mishandled it mostly
inadvertently uh but still uh that's not
something that you want on your record
um the uh program has been error written
with a lot of false positives meaning
that the employee uh was uh
misclassified as ineligible to work when
that person actually was the law
requires that the employer notify the
employee but because of the complicated
nature of these things especially small
employers might not know that and that
can get them into trouble and it also
cost the employee uh who was actually
eligible um you you know a a loss of a
job um so we would ask that um the
committee uh vote this uh bill in
expedient uh to um
legislate okay thank you for your
testimony uh any questions
representative kill thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question uh
to the best of your knowledge is there
any barrier to a an employeer who wants
to use ever verify is anyone preventing
them from using it if that's the what
they want to do no any employer it's a
voluntary program right now unless
you're in a a mandated jurisdiction so
you can do that and I should have
pointed out that as we all know every
employer every single employer has to uh
verify eligibility to U for that
employee to be um able to be hired to
work and that's through that I9 system
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um have there been
any data breaches with this program that
you're aware of in my research uh about
this program and on the ever verify
website I did not see anything about um
data breaches I should point out that in
2024 40,000 eligible employees were
initially
misclassified um Nationwide so there is
a significant um era issue thank
you representative plig again
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
coming and testifying I did get your
email thank you very much um my question
is if if someone's denied because of e
verify and there is a mistake on the
form uh the employer is supposed to
advise the the potential employee and
give them a certain time to rectify it
do they not that is exactly right um the
employer is legally obligated to notify
the employee often times that does not
happen right the employee has nine
Federal business days to uh submit the
correct information and and presumably
then get hired thank you very
much thank you and represent Mckenzie
was
ability um good afternoon thank you for
the testimony so somebody enters the uh
the system they are flagged as being uh
uh in in violation of the law so they
get flagged under the under the system
they don't correct that what is a
consequence long term for somebody who's
that's get flag like that what happens
to them in in the actual system well for
any any person that's wrongfully
misclassified because the information in
the system is incorrect it it it draws
information from both the Department of
Homeland Security and the Social
Security Administration and it's not to
determine immigration eligib status it's
to determine eligibility to work but if
those aren't corrected then this will be
repeated over and over for every system
verify Mr chair um thank you again uh
getting to the Chairman's uh question
about two-letter names and other
variations where some PE in many
cultures that people have four or five
names that may or be used in the wrong
order and I'm thinking I think last time
we talked about the uml uh which is Comm
in many Scandinavian languages are any
of these possible uh triggers for Mis
classification absolutely it's input
output so I mean I guess the good news
is both DHS and Social Security do deal
with names and obviously DHS does deal
with um names of people that might be
not in the majority uh usage like
they're not Smith's and Jones but you're
right if if it's not um entered in
properly the uh information could come
back as ineligible when the person is in
fact eligible where the I9 process which
the employers have to go through anyhow
even if they use the verify you the
employer can account for that um by
looking at the documents and not relying
on a machine thank
you any further questions representative
Sullivan thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um If an employer misuses um the uh the
system might that employer be subject to
a lawsuit absolutely probably a
discrimination lawsuit and it could be
an action by the US Department of
Justice um some employers have
wrongfully used it as a screening tool
screening only people that they believe
are not citizens or it's really supposed
to be used if you think you're going to
hire that person it's at the time that
you'd give them the I9 here let me know
that let's finish this process this is
when you use e verify but some people
use it prematurely and in in for uh
improper purposes and again with small
employers that raises the risk of
misusing it with no actual intention um
ignorance seeing no further question
questions thank you for your testimony I
appreciate it thank you thank you
guys and please introduce yourself and
who you represent thank you uh nature
Grace for the business and industry
Association uh it's Bia uh we are the
Statewide Chamber of Commerce and the uh
manufacturers Association of New
Hampshire uh we do oppose this
legislation um it would it
would create additional regulatory
burdens resulting in additional cost for
compliance for employers who do not
already voluntarily use ever verify
under existing law uh the law already
requires that uh employers obtain
documentation necessary to uh prove that
the person is eligible to work um and
that gives Employers in the state of New
Hampshire
flexibility to use the system that works
best for them that allows them to keep
cost of compliance low allows us to keep
a competitive work environment uh
because we have a voluntary system many
large employers uh choose to use ever
verify some do not uh again it all just
falls under that purpose of the system
which is um ensuring that the employee
has the ability to work in our state and
we already have that in enshrined in our
law with additional flexibility that
some other states do not allow employers
so we do not believe that this
legislation is necessary at this
time happy to take any
questions any questions from the
committee
thank
much last pin card I have
is
good afternoon thank you very much my
name is Daniel Albert I'm the Deputy
Commissioner with the New Hampshire
Department of Labor um I will attempt to
be U very brief um the department would
just relay that we have reviewed the
proposed language we understand um the
intended uh purpose of the proposed
language specifically we understand that
to be requiring all employers um to use
the ever verify system in addition to
obtaining the documentation currently
required by law showing eligibility to
work um we would also relay just as a
technical standpoint uh in looking at
the proposed language um there is the
additional or the added requirement of
employers using the ever verify system
to verify employment eligibility it
maintains the current requirement that
the employer has to maintain um
documentation for the periods uh
documentation for eligibility to work
for the periods of time required by
federal law as as phrased and in
conjunction with the added language it's
not all that clear what documentation is
being referred to is that the um
documentation showing the employees
eligibility to work you know the I9 the
Social Security C the driver's license
um in addition to the physical uh
documentation or printout used from ever
verify or one or the other um so our
suggestion would be to perhaps clarify
if the intent is for the employer to
maintain um the print out or some sort
of proof that they we've used the
everever verify system in addition to uh
maintaining the documentation showing
eligibility to work to make that clear
um because as currently uh written it's
not so clear which documentation is
being uh requested um for maintenance um
other than that I'm happy to answer any
questions should anybody on the
committee have
any representative Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman it's good to see you again good
to see you as well um in the days that
we live in now in our Southern and
I want to say this discreetly and maybe
you don't know the answer to but if
someone came up that they weren't able
to work in the state I.E country is
there any shared data with
of I I do not know okay um good I'm glad
you
didn't in the sense that um it's not
something directly regul by the
Department of Labor so I I do not know
much representative aani thank you Mr
chairman good to see you again Deputy
Commissioner um from an enforcement
standpoint from the from your department
um would this be a primary offense would
this be a secondary offense would there
be fines would there be
additional you take it from there yes no
um so I believe if I understand the
question and please correct me if I have
it wrong um are you asking whether or
not violations if found would be subject
to warning prior to penalty um yes so
for context under RSA 2731 11a certain
types of violations are subject to
immediate penalty uh on finding of a
violation um and all others are subject
to a warning with a 30-day uh correction
or cure period for the employer to
correct uh the violation U my
recollection is per this particular um
language this would be subject to
violation without
further
questions represent K so just just so
I'm clear on my colleague Mr avani's
Question uh if a if an
employer uh didn't use e verify for one
or two applicants and someone how
someone got wind of that he could be
facing uh serious
penalties I that would be correct if the
department were this language to pass
such that employers are now required to
utilize the ever verify system in
addition to the other stated
requirements and the department were to
engage with an employer and find in the
course of a labor investigation that the
employer has failed to comply with the
requirement to use e verify it would be
subject to penalty as set forth in the
statute without warning so the the um
warning with with 30 days to cure would
not be applicable thank you very much
you're
welcome okay I do have a question
regarding testimony this morning that
New Hampshire was in a full state of
employment and that many folks were
looking for workers what impact would
this law have on companies looking for
workers would it make make it harder for
people to hire do you think I don't know
that the department of labor would be in
the position to adequately or accurately
answer that question um in part large
part because we do don't engage with
Workforce Development um there are other
state agencies that engage with employ
ERS and employees more in that context
um so I don't know that we would have
sufficient information to be able to
weigh in on whether or not there would
be an impact on people looking for work
or ability to get hired okay thank you
committee all right thank you very much
thank you Miss Albert appreciate it
you're my pleasure are you going to move
your office over here now is that happy
to do so if you would like all right I
appreciate
that okay is there anyone else that
69 that being said this closes the
69 and at 1:45 we will hear HB
353 so we've got a uh 25 minute Hiatus
we cannot start early because it's
calendar so moved
minutes very
straight we could we're
not yes I understand that fully
Tom we're shooting at 3:30 and who
it's it's best you can state for tally
but you get paid $100 a year so
completely understand they have to be
here to vote though that's that is the
commitment
again
e
all right welcome back I'd like to uh
open the hearing on House Bill
353 an act relative to hearing
protection for employees of nightclubs
and music venues representative McKenzie
are you here to introduce the bill yep
awesome four your sir uh thank you Mr
chairman for the record my name is Mark
McKenzie I am from District 40 the float
in Manchester New Hampshire I'm here to
introduce uh this legislation and to
also explain to you kind of the
evolution of this since I started
working on this some time ago this
um this originally was intended to uh
protect uh people who work in um venues
music
venues and what we discovered during the
course of working on this is that there
is a demarcation between public sector
and private sector workers so you've got
the the ooser will cover uh private
sector and uh then there is there is
some information there is some rules
that cover public
sector and we have no jurisdiction over
the private sector in terms of oia right
now we hopefully at some point we you
know oia may be part of the state scheme
so the idea that we would we would
regulate that um would be a very
difficult thing to do in term in the
confines of our laws I did though during
the course of this communicate uh on a
number of occasions with OSHA
representatives and what I found out is
that they that they currently protect
workers in the private sector that they
have the authority to go in in any place
that produces news noise which is over
and above uh the recommendations that
they can go in and basically you know do
like they do any other uh uh regulation
that they can control that they can go
in and they can there ways they can uh
encourage people to uh to lower the
sound not only in music venues but in
all venues you know whether it be you
know a particular
company so let me just say a little
personal piece of This was um I had two
two experiences with with hearing loss
um one was one's my brother who has been
who's had hearing loss since he was a
child and I watched him struggl for a
number of years uh with with poor
hearing I watched uh also um the people
that I work with in the fire service who
have been exposed for a number of years
to very loud noise uh Machinery uh
engines Sirens all those kinds of things
and what you realize when you get
together as a group of firefighters and
we get together on a regular basis you
realize that many of the firefighters uh
that came my generation of firefighters
the newal guys are protected ended up
with hearing loss so we have a
preventable um something is preventable
something that we could mitigate uh the
danger involved with hearing loss uh and
so I I think that as a state though we
can't regulate the private sector we can
uh begin the process of looking at this
issue uh and potentially uh adjusting
the rules so that the rules are more
responsive uh and and provide more
protection for workers now the
Department of Labor is here and I have
been in discussions with them and as
always they're very helpful uh in in
doing uh in offering to work with us uh
on the rules now what I would suggest in
the in the rules is to mirror some of
the is currently in place in terms of
the uh the federal law and right now
there are standards under lab rules
1400 but they are different though
they're similar but they are different
so they have higher thresholds than the
federal law would have under nios and uh
recommendations so I think we can do
that but the big gap I think in the the
uh public sector under the lab rules is
that there is no long-term
uh look at so when you identify people
what is a mitigation program long term
so it's not just a matter of going in
and say well well it's loud but there
are going to be Industries where you
can't necessarily control the the levels
all the time so there's a whole process
of of of the way that you deal with with
that that is not really detailed
necessarily in the uh you know in the
state law so it's called a hierarchy of
controls so you you begin the process of
trying to move people out trying to
provide hearing protection so there's a
whole way of doing that and that's not
that is not articulated in the in the
current rules now let me say that 85
decimal uh is is a normal sound you can
go to many restaurants and do that I
would suggest so how that you go to the
Nar site and you download the app that
you can put on your iPhone and the next
time you're in a music venue or even and
that could be a small bar could be a big
one just take a look at how loud that
sound is anything over 85 decimals you
have to begin the process of backing
down the amount of time that you
actually can be exposed to it and it's
not unusual and I've been doing a little
bit of research um uh fieldwork It's Not
Unusual to go into a bar or or a venue
and have the decimals at 100 now why is
that so I can walk out I can simply walk
out of this thing but people working in
those environments can't necessarily do
that and so and so they are uh exposed
over and over again to very loud sounds
and I think this is one area that that
we can work on the state and the
Department of Labor is willing to I
think there should be more interest by
the by oser in terms of helping these
workers that said I understand that
anybody who works in clubs anybody who's
a bartender they that's a very transient
group of people
and they don't have any any
representation whatsoever there's no
workers Restaurant Association because
OSHA said we would be willing to come in
and work with people who work on those
venues but how you put those people in
one room is very difficult it's it's a
very difficult business to work in so
there's what I'm suggesting is that we
um is that we move forward with some
discussion uh in the rules to see if we
can modify the rules now we don't need
let legislation to modify the rules
that'll go in front of jel car when
that's eventually done so this bill you
could basically um if if you want itl a
bill we could do that uh if you want to
hold it in OB bance and so we come back
with the rules or I can just reintroduce
some version of it uh perhap uh next
year but this the original version that
shows is not going to it's we couldn't
necessarily uh that would not sustain a
challeng here because it's we have no
jurisdiction of private sector
so that's kind of my thing I the do is
here and if they'd like to speak uh Mr
chairman uh okay I just got it yes I'll
get to you in a second I just
gotta okay so your last statement was
that we don't have jurisdiction this
bill won't fly anyway no we we could
have we do have jurisdiction over the
public sector so there no public night
there's no public
nightclubs should be well maybe there
should be as long as rock I'm good but
yeah I what I'm what I'm saying is that
I think that uh I didn't hit the mark
when I originally put this legislation
in for specifically nightclubs okay so
okay now I understand I'm just uh
representive Flanigan and then K thank
you Mr chairman um so if I maybe I'm
maybe that was helpful because at first
you said that um it would be more for
the uh public sector because we can't
deal with the private sector but this
bill specifically says nightclubs and
music venues and I thought to the same
thing was that the state doesn't have
any music venues or nightclubs that they
own um but then you talk about so so
basically you want the employment
security people or work as comp maybe
yeah yeah to write a rule sorry followup
please yeah you want them to set up
rules within their framework through
Jael car that basic basically has these
sound limits on nightclubs and and music
venues I I would I would strike the
nightclub stuff completely on the rules
I would just say uh and you can talk to
them but but there would be a um if I
had my way it would be a a rule within
and there is currently a rule there
would be a matter of building it out
there is a rule in lab rules 1400s so be
building it out to cover public sector
not necessarily nightclubs alone but it
would be to cover um uh to cover the
public sector noise uh which they do now
to a certain extent this would enhance
the program they currently have thank
you very much representative kill thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
do you realize that many of the people
working in these music venues are
musicians and they're more likely to be
1099s if if they're
filing um and not really an employee uh
of the venue
um yes I I think the part of the
research has been to kind of uncover
unpack some the way that the industry
Works in general but having said
that representative what that's a that
to the workers is not that that's not
good for the workers in in the long run
follow up yes please thank you uh so
then your your goal is to try to protect
all the workers the the servers the uh
bartenders The Bouncer and the musicians
themselves by having some enforcement
some standards of the deciple
level the the the legislation as uh as
the direction I got to take this would
be it would only be covering public
sector workers OSHA currently has the
capacity to to deal with private sector
workers but not they don't have the
jurisdiction for the public workers so
this would be a this would be an
enhancement of lab R 1400 and there's a
number that goes with that um enhance
that so that more likely would mirror
some of the protections that private
sector workers currently have and
long-term surveillance programs AUD a
audiological testing uh all that stuff
would be rolled into the to the newest
standard under the 1400 and they're
currently looking at those rules now let
see thank you okay representative
Sullivan thank you
um you mentioned
itl and um you've also indicated that
this is um a work in progress um it
probably doesn't work for the nightclubs
but might work for a myriad of other
public sector types of employment um
might it be beneficial to um have this
um as interim study I I know that it's
not exact session yet but I just want to
get your feel on this whether it would
be valuable to have it an interm study
so that as it works through with the
department and so on um if in the end
there's a need for um uh some other type
of legislation that you can use this
bill to launch that I I think that's uh
appropriate um I did send a a note to
the to the chair and also to you and
about what I think may happen to this
legislation but if there's any any
interest to retain this and let me work
with the Department of Labor on this and
this may we may resolve this through
Jael car not need any any further
legislation on this you're right I
misspoke retain not interim study
sorry all right any further
questions thank you representative
appreciate it chairman and if we could
Summers good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Mike Summers I'm the
president CEO of the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association we
represent about 1,300 restaurant hotels
campgrounds etc etc in the hospitality
and tourism industry across the state
here testifying opposed to this piece of
legislation um I appreciate all the
field work that representative McKenzie
has done and we appreciate his um
patronage of our uh very busy businesses
um but we have some problems with this
bill uh so for example um there is no
definition for music venue so we have to
assume that means every restaurant that
has live music we would have to assume
that's going to include every facility
that would have a wedding um a wedding
party U reunions New Year's Eve party I
think anything and everything that would
have any kind of music would ultimately
get caught up in this um and frankly
that's good percentage of the
industry um because none of our business
have any expertise in this area this
would obviously require that we would
have to hire expertise whether that be
we would have to hire staff people and
then purchase testing equipment etc etc
or whether we would have to uh Source it
to a third party company either way it
ends up being a burden on the
businesses
um and then obviously some questions
about the language in the bill says
sustained sound levels must Contin Le
for an hour or two hours
um just thinking about all the events
that I've been to over the years whether
it be live music or others I'm thinking
that you know within within an hour
usually every band has taken some sort
of intermission so does then that reset
the clock and so then this becomes
pointless piece of legislation
um so that would be a question we would
have
um uh what does uh take steps to protect
employees mean exactly um is this mean
that if uh we reach this sustain this
sustained level and to protect employees
do we have to end the event or does this
mean that we have to provide earplugs um
or are we talking more like industrial
um e muff type scenarios in which case I
guarantee you there's no server or
bartender in the world is going to wear
those while they're waiting tables just
never going to happen which brings me to
my next point that in an a place like a
a nightclub type venue where you have
bartenders and servers who are
predominantly the employees working
there if they're wearing uh ear muffs or
what or earplugs or whatever how are
they going to communicate with staff
with their customers to take a drink
order order food or whatever it might be
so that just creates a whole another
level of complexity for our
businesses
um and then ultimately what's near not
clear to me also is this piece of
legislation is how is this going to be
enforced are we as businesses going to
have to essentially keep records of
every single minute of every single
event that we ever had for how long and
to what level and what format does this
have to be kept I think this just
creates a whole huge burden on
businesses um and I certainly appreciate
what representative McKenzie's trying to
do here uh you know protecting workers
but I also would remind folks that our
industry is heavily transient so the
folks that work in these facilities they
usually work there because they like
working there they like the music they
like the energy they like the excitement
um and they usually gone after a year or
two at most so usually these are very
short-term employees our industry has a
history of just turning over very
rapidly so um with that I will end and
I'm happy to try to answer any questions
you may have thank you for that
testimony any questions from the
committee repr
K thank you uh Mr chair for taking my
for question and thank you Mr Summers do
you do you see uh sh as is a viable
alternative for taking drink orders with
ear
Buffs I'm sorry repeat the question uh
would you see charades as a viable
alternative for communicating the drink
order when you're when the server is
wearing ear
muffs charades I'm going to say no oh
no it's hard enough to get a drink of
order in a allow restaurant now so yes
represent thank you Mr chairman and
thank you again Mr SU good to see you um
just a question on um how would this
impact workman's compensation you would
think it was a horror I wasn't prepared
to open um I no idea uh frankly and then
how do you prove it right then it
becomes a whole issue of uh he said she
said um you know what level I I thought
I had enough without that I appreciate
yes thank so thank you all right thank
much and if we can have uh Caroline drwy
ma'am all right good afternoon uh
representative kraton and members of the
committee an answer to your question
Language um my name is Carol andur I
live in nashwa but I'm here today as
president of the New Hampshire Academy
of Audiology so I represent audiologists
from around the state um we are asking
uh that the committee consider voting
not in favor of passing or itl uh most
of it from the way the uh the law itself
is introduced is pretty difficult to
actually even Implement um I appreciate
uh representative m en's effort and
interests and I have family members who
are in fire service so I do appreciate
that um but it's with most of your
venues as Mike said um it's just not
really diff just not doable um and have
any kind of enforcement again most of
these places would have to have a sound
they have to first test their employees
hearing to even know what what starting
level hearing they have you have to have
a good sound sound assessment which
means you're going to have to have
someone in there with microphones all
over the The Establishment for about a
week um because what you're looking at
is a Time weighted average of what is
the
approximate no noise level continuous
noise level over a period of time um and
that in these menus fluctuates
consistently it's a very Dynamic
environment uh even in your music venues
um if they're Outdoors you're better off
but even in theaters um or concert Halls
uh depending on where you sit your
exposure level is different so it's a
very difficult thing to enforce um as
far
as managing noise there are different as
he said a hierarchy the first one
preference being administrative which
means you can kind of rotate your people
around so that they're not always in the
loudest part of the establishment and
rotating can control their exposure um
in manners like that there are next down
the list are engineering controls um in
which with equipment of course you can
kind of work with the equipment when you
get into places like this again you have
to look at Acoustic treatment of the uh
establishment trying to find ways of
being able to subdue some of the
resonance and reverberation from a lot
of that noise um The Last Choice should
be hearing protection uh and again most
anyone in this kind of environment is
not going to wear a muff those the the
oer approved muffs are big heavy things
and there's no way anyone who whose job
is to talk to people is going to be
wearing those they're going to have them
hanging around their neck the whole time
um it's just ridiculous um to try to use
hearing protection standard
earplugs are not going to work well
either um as Mike like they are
completely blocking in order to work
which means immediately your employee is
going to give himself or herself a 30 DB
hearing loss plus it's going to muffle
the sound because now it's not only this
the noise in the room it's everything
that reaches your ear canal so that's
where it comes in so now you're going to
have a real hard time understanding
those people and because you are
completely uded your own voice sounds
much louder to you so you're have to be
even speaking softer it's not going to
work it's going to affect their ability
to do their job it's going to impact
their tips and that's their income
predominantly so I can't see anyone who
works in that environment willingly
voluntarily willing to cooperate and um
and do this so enforcement is difficult
those plugs are you can have specially
made custom plugs but they're costly uh
and again you still have to have people
willing to to comply and do it you
cannot just force them if they're
already hired if you're taking on a new
hire and you have a program in place you
can kind of make them sign an agreement
uh which if they violate that then they
have ter you know um reason for
termination so you can start easing
things in but it's something that would
have to be phased in over time uh and as
just the law itself I'm not familiar
with the new New Hampshire rules be
happy to look at them and offer any
suggestions but the law itself is just
not really implementable so again I ask
that you vote ought not to pass our itl
and thank you I thank you for your
testimony ma'am any questions
representative k Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh I want to
preface this with that I'm right
currently I'm having trouble hearing my
softspoken colleagues on either side of
me in conversation I don't know if
that's from too much High deciple Grand
Funk Railroad in my in my youth uh
either playing it on the on the
turntable or through the amplifier in in
the bands but I have serious hearing
loss okay so I wonder I I realize this
legislation doesn't isn't going to work
but is there some idea about uh in our
culture sort of trying to dial back the
decb when when we
listen absolutely in fact some of your
um your Apple um music and your iPhones
now have a limit of 80 DB as they're
maximum loudness and they're starting to
work with that um yeah there's a lot
going on in your case um it could be in
part because of listening to grun
Railroad to too often noise induced
hearing loss accumulates over time it
has to do with the loudness of the Expos
exposure the amount of time you're
exposed to it and how frequently you're
exposed to it and it is cumulative
gradually and slowly part of it can also
be just plain old Aging in an an
advanced technology um
highly I'm losing my sorry I just lost
my train of thought um in an
industrialized
Society just general noise around us is
continuing to get into be getting louder
so there are many efforts um as a
community but first of all you need to
get a hearing test and find out what
doing thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so if we have
constituents who work in these
industries and they're interested in
protecting themselves from hearing loss
what were some good ways to work in a
nightclub or a restaurant while
protecting your
hearing uh they again they need to
rotate they need to know where the
loudest sound is on any given day
obviously uh if they want to work on
slower days when it's not as crowded
there isn't as much conversation in the
room they can choose to work those days
rather than or reduce their hours only
they work part-time on Friday Saturday
and Sunday although again that's going
to affect their livelihood um again it's
about rotating around so that you're not
being exposed to very loud noise the
whole
time Schultz thank you Mr chair um um I
assume you work with employers currently
in the private sector if they have
concerns or with OSHA I don't I don't
I'm retired so no but I worked in a
medical office now the first three years
of my career as an audiologist yes I
work I worked in a firm that did
industrial hey conservation programs Mr
chair followup absolutely so there's a
distinction that the um Bill sponsor
made about the private sector is uh
subject to Ocean law but the public
sector in New Hampshire is not is not
would you be willing to assist if we do
have a retain retaining this bill to
work on it would you be willing to help
us strengthen that bill for the public
sector I can try I'm not don't know that
I'm as current uh on all the regulations
but maybe your Association could be but
I do I can give you the name of someone
who runs a hearing conservation program
here in New Hampshire thank you man'
sir
represent abalam thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking the question uh
what do you think of the new electronic
hearing
protectors your personal
cancelling okay um but yes but it's when
you're right in between and when that is
going on and off and on and off and on
and off because in this kind of um
establishment you're going to fluctuate
anywhere from 85 8085 up to potentially
110 so it's going to be on and off and
on and off I can't tell you how I would
like that um I'd have to experience it
Annoying all right seeing no further
questions ma'am thank you so much for
your testimony we appreciate
welcome
back good afternoon thank you um my name
is John garrian I'm general counsel at
the Department of Labor with me is
Deputy Commissioner Danielle Albert um
as representative McKenzie said uh the
department has a rule on this in
administrative rule it's
14341 um that has um an acceptable chart
of acceptable um noise exposure and it
runs um depending on the level and the
time so the chart runs from 90 DB over8
hours all the way to 114 DB for a span
of about 15 minutes um those regulations
apply to all public employers and in all
employment circumstances usually we're
talking like um machine rooms or engines
um not usually music but it applies
across the board um that rule uh as well
as our other safety rules up for read
adoption uh this coming spring uh we are
happy to work with any representative or
interested party on reviewing those um
the standards that that are in that rule
that 90 DB to 114 DB those actually
mirror the OSHA standards for um noise
exposure they are different than the
niosh standards which representative
McKenzie referred to um but they do
provide the same OSHA level protection
in the public sector I'm happy to answer
aani thank you Mr chairman and good to
see you
again um so the same question I asked Mr
summer is um how would this if you were
to overrule this and make uh requ
requirement regulations and somebody
responsible for um that how would it
affect workman's compensation granted
we're not doing the private section but
for uh public workers and also uh
liability for the state um as as well
and then I have a followup after that
yes U thank you for the for the question
uh you as I understand you're asking
about um impact on the workers
compensation system I think that would
be somewhat difficult to quantify so
employees there's nothing that bars or
precludes employees from asserting and
having valid workers compensation claims
uh due to hearing loss from noise
exposure or any other sort of uh
occupational illness or injury that they
may obtain so can be a compensable claim
um you know the impact that if the
language as proposed went into effect
that would have on the uh overall
injuries I don't know how the department
would necessarily be able to quantify
that if it is putting you know further
Protections in place to limit noise
exposure I think it's u fair or or
arguable to say that could perhaps limit
some uh injuries but I don't know that
the department would be able to put like
a firm number or give an estimate as to
you know how much that could alter or
affect uh injury claims being brought
forward but nothing would preclude a
claim from being brought forward um just
as it is right now for a followup please
um that's kind of kind of the answer um
if we were going to rule if we use rules
to enforce the regulations you know 90
Deb for so long um should we put this in
more into the protection clause for
public sector employees instead of we
were doing it through rules
I'm I may have you rephrase the question
so forgive me um are you asking whether
or or as I understand are you asking
whether it should be built into the
statute through the like the general
protections Clause
section I think that's a determination
where you know how the committee wants
to approach it I think that's a
determination that's a policy
determination I believe what attorney
garrian was emphasizing we do have an
existing rule that mirrors the OSHA
protections that in place for public
employees in all noise oriented
scenarios not just limited to
restaurants uh and and night clubs um
certainly could that be drawn up into
statute I think that it I don't think
anything would stop the committee from
doing so I think that's what this
proposal is intending to do um it also
could be addressed through the rules as
it currently is it sounds like some of
the um intent from uh representative
McKenzie is to make the rule a little
bit stricter than it currently is um to
mirror some of the I think it's naos
requirements as opposed to the OSHA
requirements um but I think it could be
approached in either way we do have
existing rules regulating the public
sector as it relates to noise exposure
so um that exists
already representative
labr thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um these days how
many claims does the department see for
hearing related comp issues
uh thank you for the question it's a
very good question I don't have solid
numbers today uh here with me right now
I will I can globally or more generally
say in the grand scheme of disputed
claims um hearing is not hearing
injuries are not a high percentage um
certainly if the committee is looking
for firmer numbers about how many
hearing related injuries are reported
per year that is a number that we could
try to generate for you okay thank you
you're
welcome representative Hall thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
is there anything you're aware of that
would prevent an employee from deciding
themselves to wear some sort of hearing
protection assuming they were able to
fulfill their job function while doing
so not that I'm aware of nor nothing
that would fall under the Department's
you okay seeing no further questions
thank you again for your testimony thank
you and
uh any other business on
353 um repr thank you Mr chairman in
light of the fact you you noticed in the
agenda that we can EXA
bills today because it's listed and in
light of the fact that the bill really
doesn't meet what the sponsor has but
would would a motion to itl be
appropriate at this time I no
okay no no we have an agreement but
we're not going to we're not going to do
it unless we both agree and I'm not
inclined to do that that's fine I'm just
saying it just didn't nothing understand
yeah we will quickly dispose of this
next week nothing against the
representative I just you know was like
okay well no it's good I got you I'm I'm
with you we'll do it next week okay this
closes the hearing on
minutes
e
all right everybody Welcome Back fire
away
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
128 an act establishing a committee to
study unemployment
insurance to introduce this bill we have
representative Granger sir the floor is
yours thank you very much Mr chair and
members of the
committee unemployment insurance is a
very strange industry it's a very
strange product every other form of
insurance that you can buy there are
multiple versions of the product that
are available doesn't matter if it's car
insurance life insurance health
insurance you can decide to have high
deductible low deductible and you can
decide what sort of coverage you need
for your particular circumstances and it
came up last year for those of you who
were on the committee last year that
there was a an interest in raising the
unemployment benefit in the state of New
Hampshire but the unemployment benefit
in New Hampshire is paid by the
employers for the employees
and so that means that we have this
strange scenario where if an employee
wants more unemployment insurance then
they don't really have any other options
there's only one unemployment insurance
and if you have six kids and you live in
a half a million dollar house and you
have the same job as a bachelor who has
no kids and lives in an apartment you
have the same exact unemployment payout
it doesn't matter what your
circumstances are it doesn't matter what
your socioeconomic background is it
doesn't matter what your priorities are
there is one unemployment plan for
everybody and this is very strange this
is the only insurance that is out there
that is like that there's other scenar
there's other insurance products that
are in a similar boat in one sense so
most of us use health insurance that is
provided by an employer or many of us do
I don't know if most of us and in that
scenario the employer is paying for it
but they usually offer more than one
plan so they have some employees and
those employees don't have any children
or dependants and so perhaps your
employer just give pays for your
insurance for free maybe you have
dependents maybe you want to tack them
on you know maybe you want to have a
higher level of insurance maybe you're
like me and you don't want health
insurance at all because you're part of
a health sharing Ministry and you that
works out well for
you when it comes to the unemployment
Insurance specifically we cannot change
it without changing it for everyone
because there's only one product and
that is the product I will tell you I
have never taken unemployment payouts in
my life ever so every dollar that is
paid on my behalf toward the employment
system unemployment system is what is is
not something that I'm ever going to see
again it's just dead weight loss now
other people there is a genuine interest
and a need for unemployment insurance
especially if you're working in an
industry where you aren't as likely to
be fully employed for a long period of
time you might want to manage that risk
of losing your job by having some sort
of Alternative Insurance for this uh
however there is none of that there are
zero options I looked like mad I found
one company that claimed to provide
unemployment insurance in the private
sector and I don't think they actually
do it's a very sketchy website I wasn't
able to get any information from them I
got a giggle over there and uh it it is
what it is so that's what this bill is
about I did as much research as I
possibly could on this subject but there
has to be some reason that this is the
only insurance industry that operates
like this where it's purely socialized
one size fits all there's no private
market for it whatsoever it's not even
like a mandate like Affordable Care Act
mandate right so if you remember the
Affordable Care Act mandate you could
buy you could choose your own insurance
provider but you had to go and you had
to have insurance otherwise you'd get
penalized on uh your tax return you I
it's it's just a Boggle to me and if I
and the reason I submitted this as a
study committee was there's no we don't
even know how to fix it because we don't
know why it's like this in the first
place now there are some that have
pretty good theories so for instance
there's the idea that since the federal
government is involved in this and
because every state has their own
unemployment scheme that crowds out the
market so it's not profitable for a
private sector insurer to actually
provide this coverage do I know that
that's the case I don't know that's the
case it's a good theory it's a you know
it might be the case um it's also
possible that there's just a strict ban
on it maybe there's some federal law
that I was not able to find that just
bans it and it's not well publicized
because people don't generally try to
start unemployment industry or
unemployment
companies but it's it's worth asking
because if you have a large family and
you have to pay for that family if
you're the sole bread winner for that
family the amount that you're going to
get on the federal unemployment scheme
might not be enough for you and there is
nothing wrong with you out of your own
pocket buying more unemployment
insurance than the state requires and if
you are like me and you don't use
unemployment insurance at all because it
you just wouldn't do such a thing then
there's no need to have you pay for it
either because that's just pure loss so
it's it's a I think it's an important
question to ask and that's why I put it
in as a study committee now if I can get
the answer like real answers not
satisfying answers but answers that I'm
satisfied are in fact the answer to the
questions that are put out in the text
then I'll be happy and then I'll be able
to figure out what to do from there but
um this this has been driving me nuts
trying to figure out out the answer to
this question why is there no such thing
as private sector unemployment
insurance and so uh I'll let you guys
ask me questions and I might not have
answers but maybe we'll find answers
okay are there any
questions I I do have a question and so
I
I'm a little bit confused by the no
insurance so my daughter has on
Employment Insurance that's
private um I mean it's specific because
she's a veterinarian she's pregnant she
had to get insurance because her company
does not provide any pregnancy leave or
anything like
that um and so she just went out and she
had to get it nine months before she was
pregnant so it wasn't a after Thea type
of thing but um is that the type of
thing you're talking about or you're
you're talking about if someone gets
laid off cuz she's going to be out of
the net for 6 months and this
this plan covers her for six months so
you talking more like a Paid Family
Leave
plan oh I mean it's an unemployment is
that she can't work so I don't know
whether that's a disability or I don't
know how they classify that so I I don't
I'm just asking if that's the type of
thing you're looking at
or well what I have in mind is more if
you lose your job unexpectedly so you're
laid off or something like that um now
that's probably related to other forms
of insurance that you can get for you
know family leave or you know workman's
comp or whatever the case may be because
there is you know workman's compensation
so but it but specifically for getting
laid off or what we would normally
provide for or would would normally be
covered by the department of un
gotcha representa Paul thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
is there any scope in your mind to
having the state employment unemployment
insurance um offerings expanded have
multiple tiers that people could choose
just like you would a health insurance
plan I think the difficulty with that is
that since the employer pays for it that
means that the customer is not the
person who's receiving the benefits and
so what would likely happen is that
employers would consistently choose the
cheapest option and uh since they're the
it yes
please so in the same way that employers
offer multiple health insurance plans
some that they pay the full amount for
others that the employee contributes to
couldn't the same thing be
done maybe uh not under the current
system and I don't know how we would go
about legislating it um but uh that that
that could that would be an improvement
at least because right because there's
then there is at least some Choice
rather than no choice
whatsoever okay thank
you do you have a question uh I'm Gonna
Save it first okay good
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking our questions uh if I see
this correctly what you're trying to do
to well first of all is you include the
senate in this you only have the house
members there's no Senate because if it
goes to the Senate they'll say they'll
either at it or they'll kill it because
they're not involved um the um but if I
understand what you're saying is you
work for me as a company okay and I have
insurance through the Department of
Employment Security and if if you get
laid off you get the $300 or $400 a week
and what you're saying is you want to be
able to buy it privately if there was an
entity out there that would sell it if
that's what the committee came up with
so that you could have more income
coming in if you lost a job from my
company right uh yeah so if if if there
is a person who is an employee and they
want to purchase an employment insurance
on on top of maybe on top of what they
are offered through their employer or
maybe in spite of or you know as an
alternative to what's provided by their
employer why shouldn't they be able to
argument represent KO thank you Mr chair
I did think of one awesome yeah uh thank
you uh representative does it stand to
reason that if the employee wanted to
buy more Insurance it might cost a lot
more than his than his employer is
paying for what he's got uh as a
standard yes
follow up please thank you and does it
seem that if there if there really was
money to be made in this and or better
service to be offered would it be likely
that insurance companies would have been
clamoring to do this even before you
thought of
it well isn't that the great question
why aren't they is is there is it
illegal I don't know um and I'm not I
don't want I don't intend to ask
questions of the committee but
rhetorically speaking I don't know the
answer to that and that's why I have a
study committee and maybe we can find
out okay thank you great thank
you representative C question thank you
Mr chair and thank you for the qu or
letting me ask the question
um are you familiar with uh companies
like afflac and supplemental insurance
companies because it sounds kind of like
that's what you're talking
about I I believe I I'm familiar with
many of the products that they offer but
not all of them I was not able to find
this sort of thing from afflac or
similar companies follow please okay so
as far as my experience goes with this
I've actually done this a little bit
with my own business and those other
ones are kind of supplemental just like
Mr chair had talked about his it was
your daughter um it seems like that's
kind of where you're leaning towards but
um again it might be more of a question
security uh maybe uh M Mr lavs was nice
enough to actually bark it up the chain
at the Federal Department of Labor and
uh they they were provided a response
but it wasn't very informative um but it
I I definitely appreciate the effort
because I I mostly just want an answer
these questions you know like um I'm a
specific policy goal is not really
what's being uh presented here although
you guys can probably figure out that I
would really like to have private sector
unemployment insurance I think that
would be a great thing for the New
Hampshire economy and just as a option
for workers in general um but um we
can't actually do that unless we
actually know what is preventing that in
the first place and it could be the case
that it is purely the market U because
there is currently a public sector
unemployment option out there it just
doesn't make any Financial sense to
compete in that market it could be the
case I don't know that it's not the case
but um it it it's worth figuring
out represent d sestro
hi thank you for taking the question so
if they have private insurance are you
thinking that they would stay out of
work
longer the whole purpose of unemployment
is to pay for a period of time when you
are not working to help carry you over
and the anticipation is you're going to
job I think it's up to people's choices
as to whether like so we don't want to
pay for for people to be unemployed for
longer than we would like to right we we
want them to generally get back to work
however if they're paying for their own
unemployment insurance far be it for me
to tell some insurance company what the
rules ought to be um if they say that we
want to encourage people to get back to
work then they can get back to work if
they want to say well um you you uh paid
for this benefit and you're going to
write it out because you have a
legitimate reason per our rules to uh
not have uh or to not have a job and you
you know you were laid off or whatever
and uh you want to write it out until
the end of the contract um and you know
and if that person never goes back to
work it's not really my job to tell them
that they must um it's it's up to you
know individual private contracts at
that point and um if if if you're
running an insurance company and you say
no you you have to be looking for a job
so right now the Department of
Employment Security spends a lot of time
and energy ensuring that people are
looking for a job and they have a
fiduciary responsibility to the
taxpayers to do that and uh that's a
great thing for them to be doing and I'm
very glad that they're um good at it uh
it makes me very happy it's it's a very
responsible thing for them to be doing
for a private company that would be in
theory you know that we're talking and
this is all you know hypothetical if
they were providing unemployment
insurance it's up to them whether they
care about telling people they need to
get back to work or requiring them to
have any work programs like my wife
doesn't work uh she's a stay-at-home mom
you know there's plenty of uh perfectly
valid reasons to not work and um it it
it's if if the if they want to have like
some requirement that you must be
looking for a job or something like that
and they want to police that on their
own I don't see it hypothetically
wouldn't be my perview to tell them not
to um but not necessarily that they
to okay representative McKenzie you good
no okay representative McKenzie thank
you Mr chairman um um we heard
earlier that the cost per employer in
New
Hampshire uh for employees is
$85 the entire cost for the program is
$85 do you believe that there is an
insurance company uh in the state of New
Hampshire or the United States of
America that would offer a policy to
protect hundreds of workers uh and could
be a big work Workforce for $85 a person
and and pay a benefit and pay the
benefits that's currently in the
system uh they may they may not um it's
it's really up to them to do a cost
benefit analysis they for for instance
hypothetically what if they only decided
to sell their services to people that
are very very unlikely to ever lose
their job or maybe they had you know
some other method that they did or maybe
they gambled all the money on the market
and made a bunch of money on it that way
or you know maybe uh we we we can only
speculate as to how exactly they would
run things and um it is entirely
possible as I said that the reason this
doesn't exist at all is because there's
no market for it um however you can
defin you you guys were making a very
good point last year when you said that
uh the amount that is currently paid out
in unemployment isn't enough so if
that's the case then why not explore
options for private sector options or PR
private sector uh
why not explore private sector options
as a
possibility rhetorically I'm not asking
members I'm not asking questions to the
committee okay all right seeing no
further questions representative thank
you for introducing the Bill thank you
for your candid testimony and uh we'll
all right sir please uh introduce
yourself and then um let's see what you
have to say all right Mr chairman uh
Richard lers deputy commissioner with
the New Hampshire Department of
Employment Security thank you uh for
having me back uh what I just handed out
to the members and I had uh provided a
copy to the sponsor on the way into
today's hearing was a response to an
email that the department had sent to
the US Department of Labor um so as I
had indicated earlier anytime there's a
a proposal to make a change to the
Unemployment Compensation Program either
on the revenue side and how employers
are taxed or on the benefit side and how
individuals qualify for benefits we
submit that to usdl they do a Conformity
and compliance review um and so it's
standard course for us to do that
nothing special with this proposal um so
we provided that we did get a quick
response um and you'll see that it's a
email back from Nicole Robertson she's
an attorney with the US Department of
Labor saying because this is just
looking to create a study committee um
there is no uh formal response from US
Department of Labor they don't deal deal
and hypotheticals uh but she did point
out that if this were to create a system
where employers were not participating
in the State Unemployment Compensation
Program and weren't paying their um um
contributions to support that program
that would disqualify them from being
able to take their discount against
their federal unemployment tax liability
uh so current ly if a state meets
Federal requirements for how it runs its
Unemployment Compensation Program and
employers are in compliance with that
meaning that they're filing their
quarterly tax and wage reports they're
paying the tax that is owed then those
employers get a 90% discount against
their Federal Unemployment uh tax
obligation so normally an employer would
be on the hook for 6% of the first
14,000 in annual earnings per employee
to the feds and with that um discount
they pay 6% so the that saves New
Hampshire employers about $200 million
per year in federal unemployment tax
obligations because the state um runs a
program that meets all of those
requirements so
um there's there's a lot um
that I could say in response to the the
testimony that was offered and into the
some of the concepts here and some of
the questions I'll try to address them
um first and foremost I don't think
anybody wants to file for unemployment
compensation I know I didn't um I
certainly did not want that when my wife
was out of work and my son was 3 months
old um but I was sure uh pleased that I
qualified and I had that support uh
during those next few months when I was
searching for employment during the
Great pandemic uh during the a great uh
recession um the pandemic I probably
wish I was uh just with the amount of
times you guys saw me um but it it's a
it's a program that was put in place in
the
1930s um there is uniformity across
States and how it is implemented it's
not by accident um when it was initially
being proposed uh by the federal
government uh states were hesitant to
participate because they didn't want to
put them eles at risk or in Jeopardy of
losing Employers in their states who
would leave their state to go to another
state that didn't tax them for an
unemployment program uh the FED solved
that problem um with what they would
have described as a carrot I think they
use the carrot somewhat like a stick um
but it was simply that what I described
earlier um if Employers in the state are
operating in a federally uh compliant
and conform forming program those
employers get that 90% discount against
their federal unemployment tax
obligation um now there are a lot of
other types of wage replacement programs
that are out there um you have I Mr
chairman uh the scenario you were
describing would be uh you know
something akin to a Paid Family Leave
program or short a short-term disability
program so um you have a qualifying
event um you receive wage replacement
for the time that that event uh
continues and then you go back to work
um there are other supplemental products
that are out there as well um you know
lots of different providers that will
provide uh supplemental payments when
you have a qualifying
event um now again the no one wants to
be unemployed um and the goal of the
unemployment program is to end that un
employment right we spend um our a lot
of our time and effort on trying to make
sure that the connections are plentiful
between hiring employers and um
unemployed individuals so we try to uh
minimize that duration of unemployment
we certainly don't create any incentives
uh to stay on unemployment longer than
you need to right now that uh wage
replacement of your unemployment benefit
being around 30% of what that average
private sector worker was earning that
certainly gives you incentive to get
back to work because that is our goal
our goal is to um help individuals with
a financial bridge to their next job so
we do that without over
incentivizing um staying out of the
labor force wage replacement uh that is
lower than what you were earning um but
enough to hopefully um allow you to
continue to pay your bills and get to
that next job so it's um
the concern that I would have and the
department does not take a position on
the bill I would be concerned with what
was described and a creating a product
that would almost on its face incent I
staying out of the labor force um our
whole system is geared towards getting
you back to
employment making sure that each and
every week that you're filing for
unemployment that you are actively
searching for work you're certifying
that to the department it's not just a a
come in and apply and here's 26 weeks
worth of benefits um and good luck it is
a constant um process with these
individuals to help them get back to
work because that is our goal so
anything that would be interpreted as
creating an incentive for people to stay
out of work longer than the labor market
dictates I would I would very much be
concerned with that and what kind of
message that would be
sending um to my knowledge um uh right
now all states have a version of what
employment security provides for New
Hampshire um there are different benefit
amounts from state to state different
number of weeks that you are eligible
for from state to state but they all
meet the basic requirements from the
federal government for having a uh
complying and conforming system so that
their employers can uh maintain that 90%
discount um against their federal tax
liability happy to answer any questions
great thank you so
much
sir thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question on a um a seasonal
work profile would representative
Granger's proposal hold a little bit
more water meaning say I own a landscape
company and we terminate on December 1st
we don't start up until April 1st that
period of time in there say that
employee is only eligible to get that
427 a week may not be enough to get him
through he may look for other employment
in a different area that's 12 months but
if he could have that option to purchase
some type of
seasonal um help if you will that may be
you may be able to retain that employee
and if it's a key employee especially um
would you view it differently if if it
was on a seasonal basis a fixed seasonal
basis um it's a good question I I
wouldn't view it any differently though
um
I talk with a lot of employers um all
across the state I you know I talk with
a lot of seasonal employers and some of
the best models that I find are those
seasonal employers who are able to um
either have something else for that
offseason or they partner up with
someone else for that offseason whether
it be the landscaping company that has a
relationship with the local fuel
delivery company so that there's going
to be work for those individuals that
are able to um have you know hold a CDL
license and drive throughout the year
because we want employment during all of
those times now right now um New
Hampshire generally requires you to
search for work when if you qualify for
unemployment however with a A change
that was made just prior to the pandemic
if you are um temporarily out of work um
and it's going to last um up to 11 weeks
your work search is waved so it's not
specific to any industry but it's really
um uh something that was U implemented
for those that have uh seasonal
unemployment where they aren't required
to search for work they get the the
benefit to which they qualify for based
upon the income that they had during
their um prior four quarters but in
those instances those individuals get a
waiver of their work search uh because
they are temporarily unemployed but for
other people that are permanently laid
off um they have a work search
requirement we're trying to get them
back to work uh right away um and again
the fundamental design is that a the
system needs to provide a level of wage
replacement that is going to be enough
to help carry you through to your next
job uh but not provide so much that it's
going to increase the duration of your
unemployment because the goal is to get
thank you Mr yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr lers U would these people
with The 11we Gap would would they be
people who have a reasonable Assurance
of repur to that
job uh it's even a higher standard than
that they have to have essentially a
guarantee that they are going to be
returning within that 11 weeks thank and
that and that gets confirmed with the
employer okay thank you very represent
McKenzie thank you uh thank you Mr Jim
um we talked a lot uh today about uh the
wage end of it but during the past
couple of years through Co and other
things can you talk a little bit about
the benefit of having a
system as it relates to supporting the
communities and stabilizing communities
at the same time not only the workers
but the communities in which they live
in the state in
general uh yeah representa there there's
a um enormous benefit to local
communities and the uh the the existence
of an unemployment program that provides
uh assistance while someone is
unemployed uh that's less Reliance upon
the local communities for General Aid uh
whether that be their welfare program or
other support programs that exist
locally um during the 18 months of the
pandemic um just to give a a sense of
the the scope of what uh
type of um economic infusion the
unemployment program can provide to the
state and also help save some of that
burden from being uh shifted onto the
local community when their their
residents go in and and seek assistance
the unemployment program paid $2 billion
in benefits over an 18month period um to
about
175,000 granted state workers uh so that
was assistance that was provided to them
that then allowed them not to need to go
to their local communities and seek
other assistance um so there is there is
an impact on local communities um but
again um we're just try we're trying to
get people back to work that is the goal
that is why we maintain a um such a
robust system of New Hampshire Works
offices where people can come in uh
receive uh free services search for jobs
um if they're filing for unemployment we
can provide assistance with that but
really to help them connect whether it
be large job fairs which the department
is the largest provider of job fairs in
the state did 65 of them last year 6,800
job Seekers attended those 65 job fairs
or whether it be a local recruitment
event local employer wants to come in on
a Wednesday when we know we're going to
have 20 people attending one of those um
benefit rights sessions that we had I
Prov Ed you a pamphlet of earlier and
that employer wants to have that
oneon-one to be able to hopefully maybe
fill some of the um needs that they have
or they're using our recruitment portals
so we have a lot of tools in place uh to
try to make sure that that duration of
unemployment is as short as it can
possibly be based upon the current
state represent King thank you Mr
chairman um I have a question for you
regarding to you said before to us that
the employer pays the unemployment
portion currently and that's how the
fund is funded so you did say that there
are supplemental things that go above
and beyond that such as like I outlined
before afflac and other services do
those other services uh they supplement
but do they is there any circumstance
where unemployment can't be used when
those services are paying out um so
that's a great question just to clarify
those other supplemental servic
the department has nothing to do with um
presumably those are um if those are
Insurance products they're registered
and licensed with the Department of
Insurance but we have nothing to do with
those however when you're when you're
filing for unemployment you are required
to report all of your work so New
Hampshire allows part-time work but
you're also you're required to report
any in all income uh during that time
period so if it's earnings from uh your
part-time employment you need to be
reporting that to us but if you get a um
surprise late bonus or a uh paid time
off payout from your employer you need
to be reporting that to the department
similar if you're getting any and a lot
of uh other types of income uh because
that may or may not impact your
unemployment benefit um one other thing
you your question made me um remember
something else that's important to to
mention um with regard to the um the the
the problems caused by unemployment you
know in a lot of instances the
unemployment benefit program isn't the
only game in town uh for an individual
worker who finds themselves unemployed
through no fault of their own a lot of
employers um also provide assistance in
those time periods whether that be with
some length of a severance or other
types of payouts um to help those
individuals um get to that next job so
you see it's very common uh with an
employer to provide some length of a
severance which you know is money being
paid to you while you're not working for
that employer um and um obviously if
there is a severance or any payment from
the employer that gets coordinated with
your unemployment benefit but that's
another way that employers are already
um trying to help their workers um guard
unemployment representative kale
CH thank you Mr LS again so again with
reporting income we're talking about
earned income whether it was uh a
saverage package that was earned
vacation that was earned but not uh not
a lottery ticket that came in right or
an inheritance or such uh unearned
income correct um everything received
needs to be reported um whether or not
it's something that counts against your
unemployment benefit is determined by
[Laughter]
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you again for being with us Mr
labers
um the you mentioned earlier uh right
now the is 6% the first $14,000 which
equates basically to 80 80 something
dollars per employee per year um in your
opinion is that a good deal for the
employers to have that kind of back stop
for their
employees um rather than me saying it it
is good or bad I can tell you I'll just
reiterate what I said earlier New
Hampshire employers have the lowest
unemployment tax burden in the entire
Northeast third lowest Third only only
behind Florida and Mississippi in the
entire country New Hampshire employers
pay at about a third of what they're
um their businesses to the south in
Massachusetts currently pay for their
unemployment program and that
$85 per worker um if
someone uh loses their job files for
unemployment they qualify for 427 which
is our current Max they collect for all
26 weeks they're getting a little over
$1,000 so for
$85 one of the lowest unemployment tax
burdens in the country
um seems to be um working out well right
business okay seeing no further
questions and having no um other pin
cards and uh people who want to testify
um going close the
hearing and we have about five minutes
on the federal portion of the
unemployment so when laid off and you
the um the federal the federal thing is
the carrot to the states to for some of
costs
e
we'll open the hearing on HB 225 uh the
bill sponsor is also our chairman um so
let's pay him a little bit of um respect
and have some fun with him thank you sir
thank you Mr
chair uh I'm here today to uh introduce
house build 225 FN an act relative to
the employment of military spouses in
the event of involuntary deployment of a
service member what this bill seeks to
do is to add a paragraph to RSA 110- C
and basically that paragraph says that
if a military member is
deployed and the spouse determines that
they canot can no longer work for what
ever reason that the company for which
the spouse Works would have to hold that
position now it's a company of over 50
people so it's not it's not a very very
small
company where this hit home for me is
that um when I
deployed we had uh situations where
soldiers
spouses uh could not run the household
take care care of the kids do the job
and those other things that normally a
team effort would do and so they either
went home or they stayed with their kids
or whatever they did but it was just too
much for them to stay at home with the
spouse
deployed and so what this bill would do
it would say Hey listen um
employer uh if if your your employees
spouse deploys I just want you to hold
that position open so there's no pay
there's no allowances there's no
compensation just when he comes back or
when she comes back uh just have a slot
open for me and uh how many people a
year I I wouldn't say it would be 10 but
at the end of the day uh if the service
member is deploying and doing uh what he
or she is told to do then I think that
we as a state should say okay there's
certain amount of sacrifice here and uh
let's just hold that job open um and
when you come back you're can have your
job back that's all it's
saying um and so just to be that simple
questions representative
L thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh how long of a
period of time would this be indefinite
like if that person was deployed for a
great question no typic the typical
employ
deployment has been up to a year but now
it's closer to nine months and I'll and
I'll allow the department to to validate
that but I know my nephew just deployed
he was gone nine months so it's not
indefinite follow follow
up would the would the bill not that you
want to amend it now but would you be
able to write that in there to cap that
in some capacity or is it already in
there and I I missed it
that deployment of one
year uh just felt
open-ended that that's a possibility
okay thank you I mean we could consider
that represent
Dro thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I curious if any
thought was given uh a couple times a
year we get bills about uh mandating
stuff for businesses or employers was
there any thought given to this as
opposed to uh making it for you know
maybe 25 employees or more um because
there's a huge difference between
mandating this for for an employer that
has maybe one employee that has to hold
the spot open as opposed to a Walmart or
Home Depot or something where they yeah
it just it says 50 in here it does if
you look under paragraph 1A oh okay well
then never mind employees 50 or more
okay solivan good thank
you
um you mentioned in your opening that um
if the spouse is unable to work um is
that subject to some sort of qualifying
factor or is it just assumed that if
your spouse is if the soldier has been
sent um on deployment that it is assumed
that if the spouse wants to uh take the
time off the spouse can yeah there
there's no consideration to proving dire
need or or something of that nature
follow follow um unrelated
on page
two um line one as I read through this
that that
section confused me um says the employer
May re-employ the
employe if the employer establishes that
its circumstances have so changed as to
make re-employment impossible or
unreasonable as defined by the statute
um
it it seems to me that it it was
intended to say the employment the
re-employ I had that same thought when I
first I'm sorry represent could you
reference the on my I don't have the
line numbers on
here the top of the page two I I hope
you've got the same I've got P section
section
you so the employer May re-employ the
employee if the employer establishes
that circumstances have so
changed or maybe what you're saying is
it should refused to it uses the word
may which is which is permissive but it
still seems vague again it seems it was
intended to say the employer may choose
not to
re-employ yeah I think you're
right okay fair enough so amendment is
in
order okay thank
you representative
McKenzie uh
so we're talking about getting the job
back are we talking about getting the
job back that they came from and I think
that's that's a distinction that we may
want to build into this thing okay thank
you
represent Mr
chairman thank you thank you for taking
my question
sure does the spouse qualify for
is that the intent I that's not my
purview but the that is not the
intention the application of
unemployment was was not part of the
discussion follow thank you Mr
chairman um so basically this is
allowing the person to take the time off
for whatever reasons and then be able to
get their job back when the
circumstances changed either person
coming back that's pretty much all
you're trying to do corre that's correct
thank you thank you very much representa
D
sylvestro and I'm sorry can I just
clarify that so that the the employer is
not firing laying off or letting go the
employee the employee is initiating
taking a leave of absence if you will
there you go so that that would not
unemployment repr D
sylvestro you just used the word leave
of absence um normally we don't want to
interfere with businesses and how they
um operate so we're asking a business to
hold a seat and I and I understand the
purpose but that employer would have to
perhaps get temporary people in so they
need to cover that job as they're going
through I was just curious were you able
to speak to any employers just run this
by anyone and and what was their answers
not representative kill
Mr chair and thank you Mr chair thank
you sir uh I know you said that the
deployment had been a year or right now
running nine months correct but it's not
out of out of the realm of possibility
that circumstances could change and it
could be for the
duration I I have no objection to to the
provision just the same but I mean it is
a possibility that as my colleague
across the aisle here uh indicated the
employer would be able to have temporary
help it's just that when the soldier
Returns the spouse would be would they
would find a position suitable position
correct thank you representative Castle
ring thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so have you done any
research if any other states do this or
anything along that line since this is
more of a state I'll leave that for for
for representative
L thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I have one final
question um what would the spouse be
afforded if anything by the armed
services is there anything that that
they would get I me there's there's a
whole Litany of Services
benefits um different programs that the
guard runs to take care of deployed
um you know obviously you got commissary
benefits you got PX benefit um you know
shopping benefits you've got all your
medical is covered okay is is there rent
and such that would coverage and help
for that morgage I leave that to the
department but I'm pretty sure if
they're activated then they get a
housing allowance okay but I I I would
leave that to them okay very good
because we normally as active duty you
are you already get housing allowance
the National Guard doesn't necessarily
get a housing Alliance but if you
activate the National Guard under title
10 then you qualify for for active
benefits and so th those would then
apply represent McKenzie uh based on the
testimony we heard earlier uh is it's
your understanding that to be eligible
for unemployment you need to be
available to work you have to be you
have to file you have to do work all
those searches so that this would in
terms of that would they be eligible for
benefits is your understanding they
would not be that's correct result of
that that's
correct K thank you Mr chair thank you
Mr chair uh do I understand that this is
limited to the guard and not active duty
Personnel like a scenario where the
soldier is is deployed overseas for an
extended period and the spouse wants to
go you know along and help take care of
the children children and would a job be
awaiting upon their return yeah so this
is the the specific um reference is to
military service members and that's
Guard Reserve and active Okay thank
you any further questions
for
chairman I just have a couple Mr
chairman if that's of course um it does
make reference to a couple of federal
sections um
especially section
seven um I'm unfamiliar with that um I I
think the department will probably speak
to that as to how that's going to be
worked in because we Department of Labor
usually doesn't enforce um particular
Federal Regulations when it comes to
protections for employees uh what was
your what was your thought on that just
to bring that definition forward into
this bill so so the I mean the thought
is that under title 10 you're
federalized and so you deploy you deploy
as a part of a federal M
action not a state action so the Guard
works for the governor until title 10 is
implemented when that service member
then becomes a federal deploy and the
still under the guard but he's
federalized thank you um that that's the
connection yep I noticed that we had uh
we had a uh save the guard Bill last
year and there was questions about
deployments that were not I don't want
to say sanctioned but not federally
authorized um would this cover um all of
the branches of employment of the
government for armed services or just
for the national guard for the state no
that's they would cover active reserve
and guard those are the three you have
three components active Garden reserve
mobilization that's all I have for right
now Mr chairman awesome thank you any
any further questions
you we have Kevin
committee thank you Mr
chairman for the record l Gentlemen of
the committee my name is Kevin Grady uh
I am a 25y year Air Force veteran and
I'm a 27y year veteran of the the town
of hooks at New Hampshire and today I'm
here representing the state veterans
advisory committee we're uh since I
don't see this committee all that often
to be honest with you um I want to tell
you what we do we're um we're chartered
by state RSA 115 colon a-8 if you want
to look us up and we're we have 20
members of our group which are from
State veteran service organizations and
these names would be familiar to you
like the American Legion or the VFW and
I personally represent the Aaron space
forces Association on the committee and
I'm their legislative chair and one of
the things that I do is I go through and
look at all of the bills coming before
the state house and I figure out which
ones have better an impact and we
discuss those bills at one of our
meetings and we take a position on them
and then I come and tell you what that
position is um a a lot of times I'm in
the position and today is one of them
where the nuts and bolts of how this is
going to work are best left to people
that are a lot smarter about things like
this than I am and that the members of
my committee uh are we support
conceptionally this idea of trying to
help out a military spouse wherever we
can a lot of people don't realize that
that if we have a guard member for
example that deploys and let's take a a
fairly lucrative career field like an IT
manager at some
place and that person deploys for for 6
months and their Air Force rank is say
an E4 or an E5 you know that person has
taken a massive deduction in salary to
to deploy on that thing because they're
now getting paid just like they were in
the active Force as an E5 or E4 living
in New Hampshire you'll get some housing
allowance credits and stuff like that
but still the base pay is going to be
Rel it's going to be the same as what an
E5 or an E4 makes somewhere else so they
they're making big sacrifices to do this
and I could certainly see a situation
where a spouse would go I I can't afford
on the money that he's now making I
can't afford child care or I can't
afford those kind of things and
therefore you know I may need to to to
go home and live with my parents you
know for for this this the four to six
months that this person is deployed but
one day we're going to come back and I
would sure love to have my job back when
and we do so I can certainly see what a
situation like this would happen um this
this bill is actually a priority type
bill for an office in Washington DC
called the defense State liaison office
we actually have three of them we're
tracking this time the others are
hp64 which adds military spouses to uh
hiring preference legislation and hp62
on protection of violence uh with
military protective orders and other
things and there's they set 10
priorities for the year and they're all
designed
to basically make sure that we're
helping out the military families
wherever we can because theyve found
that in a competitive environment like
we find ourselves in today you know it's
much it's very important to have you
know a strong family uh supporting you
when you make that decision to whether
I'm going to stay in or I'm going to go
work for the private sector or I'm going
to stay in the guard or I'm going to
going to leave the guard so we want to
want to keep these people as best we can
and and and supporting our families is
is important the last thing that I want
to leave you with is that every time I
talk to a committee I always tell them
that when one of us serves the whole
family serves so that a lot our families
make a lot of sacrifices so we can do
what we do and so we do support this
legislation and again the nuts and bolts
of you know the wording and stuff is is
is best left to people that that do that
better than we
do so subject to your question sir
that's that's really all I wanted to
tell you today thanks for the
opportunity to interview our committee
and if you're going to do a bill that
has veteran impact we're a resource that
you can use to help get the language the
way you want it and so that we're not
having to amend it next year or the year
after because there were things that we
didn't see in it well thank you for
being here before us I I I haven't seen
you before yes sir I I have seen a lot
of people in this room before I want to
thank you for your service to our state
as well thank you any questions for this
uh
gentlemen representative Hall thank you
Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question am I understanding you
correctly that a soldier deployed into a
battle space is taking a cut and pay is
that could certainly be if that person
is a is a is a National Guard
employee uh and you know they were they
were they were making six figures a year
in their job as an IT person and now
they're making 45 or $50,000 so not from
the military but they're giving up their
Civ job they're not making that that
civilian paycheck that they were making
because they've they've been activated
under title 10 and deployed and now
they're they're essentially part of the
active duty
Force so that would that would not be a
active duty sorry follow yes that would
be a guard member only that's in that
position if you're going to get deployed
to a combat zone you're going to be on
active duty and whether you start out as
an active duty member like we have an
active duty squadron at at P right now
okay about 130 or something uh Colonel
Bix will know better than me active duty
folks that are flying our tankers right
alongside of our our guard folks and
they're on active duty as as we speak
but the folks that are having civilian
jobs and they're working a standard
guard one weekend a month two weeks in a
year those folks could be looking at a
substantial pay cut in order to deploy
uh and support our country understood
thank
you representative
Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman uh more of a statement than a
question yes sir um my daughter owns a
preschool and it's like like $300 a week
for preschool the applicability in this
bill might be that if the spouse if
they're making less money the spouse
then has less disposable income to put
their three kids into preschool which
could be $1,000 a week and she's
basically or he's basically now doing
that job so there there's a there's a
concept there that I just want to share
with the members might have been more
applicable for executive sessions but I
see the applicability in this yes
sir any forur other
questions thank you thank you sir I
opportunity uh
Bixler
welcome thank you chairman and members
of the committee I'd like to introduce
for for the record my name is Nicole
desay Bixler I'm the new Deputy agitant
General as of about 5 minutes
ago so uh and I'm here to um to provide
testimony for H HB 225 I'd like to just
my esteemed colleague Kevin Grady is
also an Air Force Academy grad so we are
um we're uh brothers and sisters that
way I uh I graduated I just want to give
a little bit of background about myself
I graduated from the Air Force Academy
and did about 8 years on active duty uh
at peas Air Force Base um luring Air
Force Base and platsburg when I was at
peas is where I learned about the
National Guard and I bought a home in
Hampton New Hampshire never got rid of
it um went on did other things and I
knew that I was going to join the guard
and uh and when I got out of the Air
Force out of active duty I joined the
National Guard at peas uh in 1993 and
then um did my military service from
there about about 22 years with um with
peas at at the Air National Guard base
flying KC
135s um while I was on you know with the
military at uh at Peas I deployed on
many many missions I I deployed um from
operation
Desert Shield while I was active duty
Desert Storm to all the way through
operation Iraqi freedom and uh en
enduring freedom and while I was uh
while I was with the National Guard we
took care of my husband's mother who had
Alzheimer's and I deployed during that
time and I'm telling you it was very
difficult um that's a different you know
we really my husband did not choose to
leave his job nor did he want to we
ended up getting extra care extra
there's lots of things that you know are
happening with our families when they
deploy so it could be family issues it
could be children that need extra help
um in the case of what generated this
bill we had a gentleman who
deployed um for a year and this was in
2021 his they have five children now
they had four children then and and she
asked they had a lot of extenuating
circum circumstances with the children
and she asked her employer to T to take
a leave of absence for the year while he
was gone and they said no and so she
made do as most of our military spouses
do they make do with what they have they
get extra care elsewhere they you know
they can call on the Squadron or the
commander or their their outfit and and
get help from our family services
there's we have a lot of ways of getting
help so to answer that question from
before we do have a lot of services that
we provide to our spouses but in this
case it would have really helped her to
be able to take a leave of absence from
her job so that she could care for her
family um she had a mother-in-law who
was who eventually she died of covid
complications and that was during this
time period so there were a lot of
extenuating circumstances in her case um
and and I and I just want to kind of um
get to some of the questions out there
how many people would this affect I
don't think that it would affect a lot
of our spouses I don't think that
spouses are you know you're your
military member is going to deploy I've
deployed many times I don't think I ever
heard my husband say once that he wanted
to leave his job that was him not all
spouses are the same but there you know
I don't know too many military spouses
that are going to say I'm going to take
a leave of absence for one full year but
we have more and more complications with
family and um situations that come along
that it might it might affect so it
would it would help the few maybe the
Dozen who would take advantage of this
type of thing and to get to the employer
you
know I suppose it would be an extra cost
they would have to um you know hire
somebody a a sub or you know aemp person
for a while um so we do understand that
that would be a cost but we feel that it
would be a minimal cost to the employer
because it wouldn't affect that many the
way that we have you know written the
bill and
uh
so thank you for your time I'll take
your
questions y one again thank you and
thank you for your service thank you
representative
Warden thank you and thanks for your
testimony today you cited a specific
example of a family you said four
children one on the way and she needed
to be home with the family correct
correct do you recall the what employer
that was that she had at the
time I do not know the employer
um follow up so it was before my time at
as the deputy agitant General so um I
could get that information for you if
you wanted question of that is was was
that employer
employing more than 50 people yes or was
McKenzie this is a u this is a question
uh
regarding whether or not employers
discriminate against people who present
themselves as active members uh in the
guard and whether or not that would be a
disincentive for employers to hire
somebody
which would be I think would be a
disservice in so many ways but I'm
curious if you've ever bumped up against
that we have a program called employer
support of the gard and reserve and they
are there to handle those types of
problems with our employers so they're
um they are made up of uh mostly retired
Guardsmen who go out and meet with
employers and they have activities with
the you know they have with employers to
um to educate them on the needs of
Guardsmen but I would say that most
employers are are are extremely
supportive of and even in this case that
I gave you with uh the gentleman the
soldier who deployed and his wife she's
she according to what I know from that
situation she has said before that her
employer has bent over backwards in
other cases it they couldn't manage it
then and I know it was during the the
covid period it was a difficult period
for everybody on all so maybe there were
extenuating circumstances that way as
well but I would say that mostly um we
encounter employers that are very
supportive of and they like the energy
and you know our Guardsmen are do
several things at one time you know we
had a pilot at peas who was also a
president of a financial company in
Boston so in that in the case that Kevin
Wasing talking about um yes every time
he deployed he he was making less money
than he did as a civilian so but he did
it because he loved it and he he wanted
to serve his country and you know and
his wife was very supportive so you know
we we make things work one followup
question follow did you say at the
beginning of this that you would just
promoted sir I just got into this
position yes so I retired in 2014 I
became a real estate broker so I am a
broker in New Hampshire and um Maine uh
I still have an active license um but I
don't do real estate I don't have time
to do real estate with this job but yes
I was appointed November 15th
congratulations so I'm the new Warren
Perry if you knew who Warren Perry was
I'm the new Warren Perry congratulations
that's thank you that's your mic thank
you representative
cing thank you Mr chair um so I have a
question you've had extensive experience
with the private sector sounds like with
employ our employers and stuff is there
any companies that you'd point to that
maybe have a policy like this that do
support uh the spouses or anything like
that that might that we could look at or
that we could
any would you like me to put you in
contact with our um employee uh employer
support of the garden Reserve our office
there I can do that sure
they have contacts with lots of
employers and may have some insights
there
good afternoon again John garrian
general counsel with the Department of
Labor and with me is Daniel Albert uh
Deputy Commissioner with the Department
of
Labor uh very briefly we have reviewed
the bill um and we feel that we can
enforce and administer the provisions of
the bill with no no issue um one minor
technical note on the wording of the
bill um we put this in our fiscal note
in section
8B it references the second sentence of
that section that uh a court may also
award the employee reasonable attorney's
fees and costs um there's no other
reference to a court procedure within
the bill as written we would assume that
um it was intended that uh any award of
attorneys fees or cost would come out of
the Department's administrative hearing
procedure so just a technical note there
but other than that I'm happy to take
questions um to hopefully provide you
some answers about what we
do any questions for Mr garrian
representative Warden thank you Mr
chairman what percentage of
companies more or less in the state have
50 employees or more bpart uh I don't
have that data the department doesn't
keep that data that would be a better
question for the Department of
Employment
Security follow up follow up thank
you and you mentioned the reference
section 8B the court may also award the
employee reasonable attorneys fees is
that
common language and other types of
violations of this nature for against
employers uh it's similar to um the
language that exists now in RSA U 110c
as it pertains to employ protections for
members of the National Guard um there
are similar language there that
statute as it pertains to the current
service members has a more um more
detailed process by which there's a
mediation uh then the Department of
Labor is involved if and then if the
Department of Labor um needs assistance
enforcing the end result it can go to
the Attorney General's office if the
Attorney General's office uh it can
proceed in Superior Court if the
Attorney General's office declines to
proceed in Superior Court the service
member themselves can proceed in
Superior Court and then the court May
award um attorneys fees and costs as
well as as other Equitable relief so um
that line also appears in there um this
bill is written seems to only
contemplate a uh administrative
proceeding um so it just if it's going
to have an administrative proceeding we
would just want to make sure that that's
all all lined up if there's going to be
a core proceeding then those details
there thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question would this be a
on a violation would this be a warning
first type situation because of the
obscurity of this and and how it's kind
of buried in the weeds most employers
may not know this that's an excellent
question um as it's written right now uh
my understanding is that this bill would
only allow for um the Equitable relief
that's included in it would not fall
under the typical purview of the other
uh labor laws that have the more um the
structure of warnings and then um and
then F so there's no fine provision here
uh it would allow the department to
order somebody to be um reinstated and
Order back pay and other benefits lost
so it would be fall out of the typical
procedure represent
Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman on that same note about repeat
offense and so forth I don't think I'd
want to be a business in which they
repeatedly offended this law about
spouses of militaries that are being
deployed I think it would be the worst
thing they could ever have from a Public
Relation standpoint again maybe
something for executive session was that
a question representative Flanigan if
you
agree I I I never encourage any business
to break any New Hampshire
law representative wardon thank you to
your knowledge is there any current
statute or rule that prohibits a company
from
extending uh leave of absence to an
employee for whatever reason let's say
for weeks or months without paying that
person so a different
way can companies already do this
voluntarily or would that be against
statute uh to the Department's knowledge
there's no statute that prohibit such a
thing that would fall to a company by
representative
Hall thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking my question um reading through
Section
8 it strikes me that it may not be until
after the deployed spouse returns from
Duty that you could claim there's a
violation of this is that how you would
interpret that at the
do so the bill is written would um allow
employees who believe they have been
subjected to a violation um to file a
complaint within 180 days of the alleged
violation um there's no provision here
that would set a specific timetable for
when a hearing would have to be held um
typically hearings uh that are filed or
sorry I should say petitions for
hearings that are filed tend to be
scheduled within two to three months
depending on the type of hearing some
have to be faster logistically so um it
could very well be that it happens after
fact and perhaps reinstatement or back
payer are kind of a retroactive thing at
that point uh followup Mr chair please
um my question is more along the lines
of there's no if I'm unless I'm missing
it there's no provision in the bill for
the employer to give an
affirmative response to the employee
saying yes you definitely will have your
job
I I don't see that language yeah all
right so so so do you agree that that is
language that would need to be added
potentially to remove that
confusion yeah the department will take
a policy position on whether that
language should be in there or not I
will agree that fair I don't see the
words there yeah I I'll leave that to
the the policy experts thank you just
just for clarification were you speaking
of section seven that we had some
question on the language May employ May
re-employ is that what you looking at
instead of no the question was
more
that it seems the employee who feels
they've been subjected to a violation of
this statue can't may not have standing
to to state that until their spouse
returns from mobilization and they go to
ask for their job
back well it's a
combination um so the they believe
they've been subjected to a violation is
two but
how do they know they've
been they've been subjected to a
violation until their spouse returns and
they go ask for their job back because
there's nothing in the in the section in
section two that requires the employer
to give them something in writing that
they'll get their job
back right that and that's my point is
they if
the deployed until the deployed spouse
comes
back they can't ask for their job back
which means they can't have the employer
can't have violated the statute until
that
happens so I'm gon gonna try and
summarize uh that so if the non-employee
was deployed and the employee wants to
take a leave and then come back before
the deployment is
over no my question is just can the
employer can the
employee bring an action against the
employer immediately when the employer
says you I'm not keeping your job open
for you or do they have to wait until
the deployed spouse returns in order to
make that determination that's a little
clearer
so um under the proposed language under
section two
um I think it covers kind of a broader
range of potential things that could
happen in that employer employee
relationship it says that an employer
shall not discharge refuse to hire or
take any adverse employment action
against an employee based on the
involuntary mobilization so it's likely
there could be actions that could be
brought um at any time during the
mobilization or afterwards depending on
what happen seems like it's trying to
capture a broader cross-section of
employment
situations representative kill Mr chair
uh Mr garan would it be uh practical and
feasible for us to put something u in
section five stating after the um
employer is notified that they shall
respond uh to let to advise the employee
uh whether or not the Le will be granted
and and then of course they return in
section six that's when they return and
you know from the mobilization and seek
their job back and I think they would
know going in whether or not it's going
to be approved it has
approved
yeah
um uh yeah the department won't take a
position on on how best to fit that in
as a as a policy I think there are a lot
of considerations that could be play in
in that
interplay
you thank you Mr chair from a violation
perspective from the Department if this
business is sold or bought out then how
forward that's an excellent question
um
it it can be difficult um we certainly
have cases where the department is
seeking civil penalties typically um
against businesses that have sold or
been bought out sometimes um that
liability would will extend beyond um
the time where they either file for
bankruptcy or they close their doors
there are there are there's a winding up
period where Claims can be brought
sometimes the department is is chasing
um companies through bankruptcy or
through through auctions we have an
ability to um to lean when it comes to
civil penalties here in terms of
reinstating an employee to a job that
doesn't exist because the business
doesn't exist I think that would be that
would be difficult to do um but it could
be that the department has an ability
under some of its existing um Provisions
to seek um the back pay and some of the
financial reimbursement restitution
follow thank you Mr chair the reason I
ask this is you may have businesses that
have to disclose this upon tra you know
selling from one entity to the other and
this could be a determining factor in
whether that deal goes through or not so
there would need to be complete compl
Clarity in where this lies in order to
make that transaction happen so I would
think the department have to be real
sharp on this just just a thought thank
you yeah I think if any Clarity wanted
to be added to the bill on that ground I
would leave that to the to the
legislators to to determine what the
best policy wording is for
that any further questions for Mr
garrian or the department
itself um I have a couple um definition
of
spouse
um what if they're not married and
they're long-term Partners would there
still be some qualification issues or um
because I know definition of spouse has
changed through the years I think as
written in the bill right now it's
legally married I think if the committee
wanted to revise that to include a
broader range
of uh Arrangements
um that that's certainly a policy
decision thank you um and along the
lines of what everybody was talking
about liable for
reinstatement um if the employer let's
say you know they've been gone for a
year they've DED up their job between
three different people and they come
back for their job their job no longer
exists technically no longer exists
because of the changes they made in
order to cover that job would they be
mandated to rehire that person in their
original
capacity uh the bill provides for or or
the application of what is a federal
standard I admit I'm not familiar with
that Federal standard
um but it it there could be
circumstances where
perhaps it seems that the bill is
intending that there are times where
reinstatement is not possible and
therefore employers are kind of relieved
of this or perhaps there's a time when
reinstatement is possible and um
employers haven't met that I'm not
familiar with that Federal standard um
so that leads me to my next question yes
um for that definition
uh I know that a lot of our state laws
sometimes will conflict with certain
federal stuff um would we need to add
that to our Protections in 275 for
employees as well that type of
yep I want to make sure that if if
somebody comes to the de well saying
okay well we're using this Federal
standard but it's not in state law is
the is the employer going to be able to
argue that well the state shouldn't be
enforcing that it should be Federal and
then our this is
becomes that's an excellent question and
I think it may involve uh a thorough and
Nuance legal answer so I may uh if it's
okay I may get back to you on that that
there's a lot there's a lot to unpack
there legally in that question I'll make
sure I get you the right
answer thank you um it was definitely a
thought when I was looking at it as from
an employeer standpoint any further
questions for Mr garrian or of the
Department of Labor on this particular
Bill seeing none I will any further
anybody else wish to speak on this
bill perfect then I will close the
hearing
you you ask the chairman when he gets
yeah
yeah those could change right and then
then we don't know well those are is the
CFR yes okay did you want to re
reexamine I can reopen
be defitely
small okay yeah we do is is next week
we'll